वी आर लाइव
ओके लेट मी सी हियर या आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
नाउ
अ चलिए एक बार मुझे एक बार सभी लोग एक बार
बता दीजिए फटाफट बता दीजिए इफ आई एम लाइव
गाइस इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल ऑडियो
वीडियो सब कुछ सही है बिल्कुल परफेक्ट है
एक बार जल्दी से बताइए फटाफट
ओके गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते नमस्ते
गुड इवनिंग सभी को भाई सभी को गुड इवनिंग
एंड नमस्ते
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
आप सभी [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] को गुड
इवनिंग एंड नमस्ते
चलिए
ओके
आज की क्लास स्टार्ट करेंगे उसके पहले एक
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट अनाउंसमेंट एंड बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट अपडेट है आप सभी के लिए है।
बहुत ही इंपॉर्टेंट अपडेट है। अ मजा आएगा
आपको सुनके। कई लोगों को आईडिया लग गया
होगा मैं किस बारे में बात करने वाला हूं।
जरा गेस करो।
एक बार गेस करो।
किसके किस बारे में मैं अपडेट
देने वाला हूं। अभी जल्दी गेस करो क्योंकि
बहुत बड़ी अपडेट है। अ बहुत बड़ी चीज है
एंड सभी को आपको जानना चाहिए इसके बारे
में। सो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सभी को आने देते हैं एक बार पहले।
सर्टिफिकेशन
नहीं कुछ और है। सर्टिफिकेशन नहीं है। कुछ
और है।
सर्टिफिकेशन नहीं है। कुछ और है।
हम राइट एथिकल हैकिंग की वीडियो अ आपको
आने वाली है मिलने वाली है बहुत जल्द चैनल
पे अपलोड हो जाएगी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जो कि मैं आपको
सब कुछ क्लेरिटी के साथ बताता हूं थोड़ी
सी एक मिनट लूंगा मैं आपका बस ओनली उसके
बाद आज की शानदार इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक
स्टार्ट करेंगे फिशिंग का टॉपिक है आज का
एंड हम साइमुलेशन एंड फिशिंग के तरीके के
किस तरीके से आप फिशिंग को एग्जामिन कर
सकते हैं एज एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट क्योंकि जब
आप एक एसओसी सॉक एनालिस्ट बनते हैं ना तो
आपका बहुत एक बड़ा मेजर पार्ट आपका जो है
इन्वेस्टिगेशन का वो फिशिंग एनालिसिस में
चला जाएगा। फिशिंग अटैक्स इतने ज्यादा
होते हैं, इतनी ज्यादा वैरायटीज हैं उसमें
कि आपको ये बहुत इन डेप्थ जो है ना आपको
इसका कांसेप्ट समझना पड़ेगा। ठीक है? तो
हम उसको देखेंगे। बट उसके पहले मैं बता
दूं कि हम बहुत जल्द हमारे डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी YouTube चैनल पे एक ऐसी एथिकल
हैकिंग की वीडियो लेकर आने वाले हैं जो 5
1/2 घंटे लगभग जितनी बड़ी है। वीडियो
फाइनल हो चुकी है। एंड यह पार्ट वन होगा।
अब इस वीडियो को लाने के भी पहले एक छोटी
सी 4- 5 मिनट 10 मिनट की अनाउंसमेंट
वीडियो आएगी उस पर्टिकुलर कोर्स के
रिगार्डिंग। वो एक वन शॉर्ट कोर्स होगा
पार्ट वन। पार्ट टू भी आएगी उसकी जो आपके
रिस्पांस पर डिपेंड करता है। अगर उस पार्ट
वन पर हमें अच्छा रिस्पांस मिलता है एंड
हमें लगेगा कि यस पीपल आर एक्चुअली
इंटरेस्टेड टू लर्न फ्रॉम दैट फ्री वीडियो
क्योंकि हमने पहले उस वीडियो के लिए सोचा
था पहले कि हम उसको पेड रखेंगे। हमने यह
सोचा था कि वी विल अपलोड ऑन द YouTube इन
मेंबर्स ओनली एरिया। मेंबर्स ओनली का मतलब
कि हम एक मेंबरशिप का फी रखेंगे पर मंथ का
और उसको हम उसमें अपलोड करते जाएंगे। ऐसी
वीडियो जो भी होंगी हम उसी में अपलोड
करेंगे। पहले ये हमने सोचा था। बाद में
बहुत सारी चीजें हुई। बहुत सारी चीजों को
सोचने के बाद वी थॉट कि मेंबर्स ओनली
एरिया में आई डोंट थिंक कि इतनी ज्यादा
पब्लिक तक वो वीडियो पहुंच पाएगी जितना हम
एक्सपेक्ट कर रहे थे उस वीडियो से। तो
हमने उसको फ्री करने का सोच लिया कि वी
विल पुट इट एब्सोलुटली फ्री। पार्ट वन
जितना रिस्पांस पार्ट टू उतनी जल्दी आएगी।
अब यहां जो अनाउंसमेंट वीडियो आएगी आपको
इस पर्टिकुलर एथिकल हैकिंग के वीडियो के
लिए जो आपको चैनल पे मिलेगा। यह वीडियो
अपलोड होने से पहले एक अनाउंसमेंट वीडियो
आएगी 510 मिनट की। उस अनाउंसमेंट वीडियो
को आप लोग सभी लोग देखिएगा। क्यों?
क्योंकि उस अनाउंसमेंट वीडियो में हम एक
ग्रुप का लिंक देंगे WhatsApp ग्रुप का।
एंड आप सभी उस ग्रुप को जॉइ कर पाएंगे। अब
वो ग्रुप क्यों होगी? उसका भी मैं आपको
रीजन बता देता हूं। वो ग्रुप होगी एक
सपोर्ट ग्रुप। अब आप यह सोच रहे होंगे कि
अरे सर ऐसे तो एथिकल हैकिंग की वीडियोस
डाल के व्यूज लेने के लिए बहुत लोग डालते
हैं। ऐसे वीडियोस बहुत सारे लोग का
क्वेश्चन ही हो सकता है। बट उन बहुत लोगों
में से क्या कोई आपको सपोर्ट प्रोवाइड
करता है? एक फ्री हैकिंग की वीडियोस अगर
फ्री एथिकल हैकिंग की वीडियोस हैं। 5 1/2
घंटे की वो भी सिंगल पार्ट। अगेन दूसरा
पार्ट वो भी 5 6 घंटे की होगी। लगभग 10 11
12 घंटे की टोटल वीडियोस के और वह फ्री
में आपको मिल रहा है। उसके सपोर्ट कौन
देता है? कोई नहीं देता है। नोबडी इज़
क्योंकि टारगेट एंड मेन हमारा जो मेन
आउटपुट उसको चाहिए होता है क्या कि चलो
व्यूज आ जाते हैं। दैट्स इट। खत्म कहानी।
उसके बाद कुछ नहीं। यहां पे मैं आपके लिए
एक WhatsApp ग्रुप बनाऊंगा। एंड उस ग्रुप
को आपको उस अनाउंसमेंट वीडियो के अंदर
लिंक मिलेगी। उससे ज्वॉइ करना होगा। उस
ग्रुप को आप ज्वाइन कर लेंगे। वहां सभी
लोग कलेक्ट हो जाएंगे। एक जगह इकट्ठा हो
जाएंगे। एंड वहां उस पर्टिकुलर कोर्स से
रिगार्डिंग कोई सा भी आपका क्वेरी होगा
क्वेश्चन होगा तो एक कम्युनिटी टाइप फॉर्म
हो जाएगी। वहां [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
उस ग्रुप में हम आपके लिए अवेलेबल रहेंगे
और आपकी क्वेरीज को रॉल्व करेंगे। आपके जो
भी क्वेश्चंस होंगे, आपके जो भी डाउट्स
होंगे, उस पर्टिकुलर कोर्स के रिगार्डिंग,
उसमें जो वीडियोस जो उसमें चीजें टॉपिक
पढ़ाई गई हैं, उसके रिगार्डिंग और और
जितने रिसोर्सेज आपको चाहिए होंगे वो भी
हम आपको उसी ग्रुप के अंदर प्रोवाइड
करेंगे। उसका कोई पैसा आपसे नहीं लेंगे।
सपोर्ट का, रिसोर्सेज का, कुछ का भी आपसे
पैसा नहीं चार्ज किया जाएगा। यह एक गारंटी
के साथ मैं बोलता हूं। ऐसा आप लोगों को लग
रहा होगा कि सर आप लग रहा है सपोर्ट देंगे
तो कुछ पैसा वैसा लेंगे या कुछ ऐसा ऐसा
कुछ भी नहीं है। फ्री होगा सब कुछ। दैट्स
इट। तभी तो फ्री होगा ना। नहीं तो फिर वो
तो बेवकूफ बनाने वाली बात हो गई कि हां
सपोर्ट के नाम पे पैसे ले लो। कुछ के नाम
पे पैसे ले लो। तो हम फ्री में देंगे। बट
वो ग्रुप जरूर ज्वाइन करना है। ठीक है? बस
ये एक अपडेट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] है
आप सबों के लिए। एंड वहां पे आपको सपोर्ट
प्रोवाइड किया जाएगा। इवन आप उसमें
क्वेश्चन जब करेंगे तो हो सकता है आपके
फेलो जो लर्नर है वो भी आपको आंसर कर दे।
बट हम भी अवेलेबल रहेंगे आपके लिए एंड
वहां पे आपको सपोर्ट प्रोवाइड करेंगे।
दैट्स इट। सो बता दीजिए कैसा लगा आपको यह
अपडेट। और हां ये जो वीडियो होगी यह सिर्फ
बिगिनर लेवल के लिए नहीं होगी। बिगिनर से
स्टार्ट होगी। बट ये आपको एक अच्छे खासे
लेवल पे लेकर जाएगी। इंटरमीडिएट लेवल तक
लेकर चली जाएगी। यह कोर्स बनाने का सबसे
बड़ा रीजन एक ही है। सिर्फ एक रीजन है और
वह रीजन है कि जो बंदे
नहीं दे सकते पैसे।
मैं उनके लिए यह कोर्स ला रहा हूं जो बंदे
₹500 भी नहीं दे सकते। 1000, 2000, 5000
की बात छोड़ो। जो बंदे ₹500 भी नहीं दे
सकते। हालांकि अपने स्किल्स को एनहांस
करने के लिए लोगों को पैसे एक्सपेंस जो है
ना वो हालांकि करने ही पड़ते हैं। पैसे
लगाने पड़ते हैं। लगाने भी चाहिए क्योंकि
आप स्किल गेन कर रहे हो। मोबाइल रिचार्ज
और इधर-उधर की चीजों में कितने पैसे खर्च
हो जाते हैं। लगाने जरूर चाहिए। बट हो
सकता है आप में से कई लोगों के पास वो
अमाउंट भी बड़ी मुश्किल से आ रही हो। बहुत
मुश्किल से आप कलेक्ट कर पाते हो। नहीं
हो। आपको उस पर्टिकुलर एथिकल हैकिंग की
कोर्स वीडियो वन शॉट वीडियो में एक प्रॉपर
रोड मैप मिल जाएगा। एक प्रॉपर
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड लर्निंग मिलेगी एंड एक कोर्स
वाला स्ट्रक्चर ही मिलेगा। साथ में सपोर्ट
आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा है। बस दैट्स इट। अब
आपकी वो
इच्छा है कि आप उस वीडियो को शेयर करें।
आप उस वीडियो को लोगों तक और लोगों तक
पहुंचाएं। क्योंकि आपको जब मिल रहा है
फ्री में तो और लोगों को भी तो आप
पहुंचाएंगे। उस वीडियो को आप हाइप करें।
क्योंकि जब भी आप कोई वीडियो देखते हैं तो
नीचे हाइप का बटन होता है। जितना आप हाइप
करेंगे वो वीडियो उतनी ज्यादा ट्रेंड जाती
है। मतलब वो YouTube उतनी ज्यादा रिकमेंड
करता है उस वीडियो को दूसरे ऑडियंसेस के
पास। यानी दूसरे व्यूअर्स के पास उनके फीड
लिस्ट में YouTube जब वो ओपन करते हैं तो
वहां पे शो करता है। तो यह आपके हाथ में
है। यह मैं आपके हाथ में छोड़ता हूं कि
उसको कहां-कहां तक पहुंचाना है WhatsApp
ग्रुप्स में, Telegram ग्रुप्स में,
Facebook ग्रुप्स में, inा पेज पे, Lindin
पे कहां-कहां आपको डालना है, दैट विल
डिपेंड टोटली ऑन यू गाइस। उसमें मैं आपको
कभी फ़ नहीं करूंगा। आपकी मर्जी होगी। बस
आप फैला देना। अगर आपको लगेगा कि वह वर्थ
है तो बिल्कुल। अगर आप उनसे कुछ सीखेंगे
तो आपको रिटर्न में कोई पैसा नहीं देना।
कुछ भी नहीं करना। जस्ट उसको फैलाना है
जितना आप फैला सकते हैं। दैट्स इट। खत्म।
बस ये अनाउंसमेंट थी। ठीक है?
गॉट इट। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] चलिए।
सो नाउ लेट्स स्टार्ट द टुडेज़ सेशन। आज का
जो सेशन है, मैं लिटरली बता रहा हूं। बहुत
बहुत ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाला है।
उसको हम स्टार्ट करेंगे। उसके पहले मैं
आपको बता देता हूं जो आपको दो-तीन चीजें
करनी होती है हमेशा से करनी होती है
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी YouTube चैनल पे जाइएगा
लाइव सेक्शन में एसओसी की कोई सी भी
वीडियो उठा लीजिएगा एसओसी क्लास की ठीक है
जैसे पिछला कोई से वीडियो उठा लिया आपने
अब यहां पे एसओसी जो आपने उठा लिया है तो
अब देखिए अब यहां पे एक सेकंड
हम अब यहां पे आप इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में
जाएंगे तो आपको दो लिंक मिलेगा एक
WhatsApp चैनल का मिलता है एक WhatsApp
ग्रुप का मिलता है WhatsApp चैनल को जाके
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा 13000 लोग इस हमसे जुड़े
हैं क्योंकि हमारे साइड से कुछ भी अपडेट
जो होती है ना कुछ भी एनीथिंग रिलेटेड टू
एवरीथिंग वह सबसे पहले आपको इसी WhatsApp
चैनल पे मिलेगा। उसके बाद WhatsApp ग्रुप
एसओसी की स्पेसिफिक ग्रुप है जिसमें एसओसी
के रिसोर्सेज एसओसी रिलेटेड जो सारी चीजें
अपडेट इनफेशन वो आपको इसी में मिलेगी। तो
इसको जरूर जॉइ कर लीजिएगा। बीइंग एन लर्नर
ऑफ़ दिस एसओसी सीरीज। उसके
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बाद यह मेरी
Lindin प्रोफाइल है। आप चाहे तो मुझसे
कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। 13500 लोग जो हैं वो
कनेक्ट हो चुके हैं अभी तक। मेरे से
इंटरेक्ट करना है अगर आपको तो आप इस
Lindin पेज पे आके कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं
मुझसे। ऊपर यूआरएल है। आप यूआरएल के थ्रू
डायरेक्ट ओपन भी कर सकते हैं। साथ ही में
अगर आप डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च करते हैं Lindin
पे ही तो डिफ्रॉनिक्स साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
Lindin पेज मिल जाता है। यह हमारी कंपनी
पेज है। हमारी कंपनी की तरफ से जो भी
अपडेट्स हमारी व्हाटएवर वी आर डूइंग व्हाट
थिंग्स वी आर ट्राइंग टू डू कैसे सारी
चीजें जो है आपको इस पेज के थ्रू मिल
जाएगी। तो आप इस पे लगभग 22,000 लोग हमसे
जुड़े हैं। आप इसको फॉलो कर सकते हैं। यह
हमारा [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
Instagram का पेज है डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
जहां लगभग 48,000 पीपल आर फॉलोइंग अस। एंड
यहां पे आपको इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल रील्स,
कंटेंट्स, पोस्ट मिल जाया करेंगे। तो,
इसको जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। साथ ही में यह
हमारा एक्स का पेज है। इसको जरूर फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। यह हमारी वेबसाइट है। आप वेबसाइट
को एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। बहुत जल्द
वेबसाइट का लुक एंड फील सब कुछ चेंज होने
वाला है। अ सारी चीजें तो इसको फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। यह हमारा WhatsApp नंबर है। इस
पर आप हमसे किसी भी तरह की क्वेरी
क्वेश्चंस पूछ सकते हैं। राइट? Accademy
पे जाके आप हमारे कोर्सर्सेस को एक्सप्लोर
कर सकते हैं। ये जो है ये मेरी पर्सनल
Instagram प्रोफाइल है। आप इस पे भी आके
मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। फॉलो कर सकते
हैं। राइट? चलिए
ये सारी चीजें हो गई हैं। नाउ लेट्स अ
रिमूव दीज़ थिंग्स।
अब आज की टॉपिक स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं
आपको क्लियर इंस्ट्रक्शन देना चाहता हूं
कि आज की जो टॉपिक है वो बहुत ही ज्यादा
बहुत ही ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है बीइंग एन
एसोसिए एनालिस्ट। ठीक है?
बहुत ही ज्यादा। ठीक है? अब इन टॉपिक्स को
ठीक है? इन टॉपिक्स को करने के लिए आपको
आप पेड कोर्स करो या कुछ भी करो यह
टॉपिक्स आपको करने ही करने हैं। पढ़ने ही
पढ़ने नहीं सीखने सीखने हैं क्योंकि हम आज
फिशिंग एनालिसिस एंड सैमुलेशन पढ़ने वाले
हैं। आज के इस क्लास के लिए कोई आपके लिए
कोई पीपीटी नहीं है क्योंकि मोस्टली
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन और एक्चुअल चीजों को हम
देखेंगे। किस तरीके से एनालिसिस करते हैं
वो सारी चीजें देखेंगे। एंड आज की चीजें
मैं आपको बताऊंगा एकदम डिटेल में वो है
ट्राई हैक मी प्लेटफार्म को यूज करके
क्योंकि आज के टॉपिक के लिए ट्राई हैक मी
प्लेटफार्म के पास जो इंफॉर्मेशन है उससे
बढ़िया इंफॉर्मेशन आपको शायद जल्दी कहीं
नहीं मिलेगी। हालांकि आप इंटरनेट से
Google वगल करके तो बहुत कुछ पढ़ सकते
हैं। मैं उसके लिए मना नहीं करता हूं। आप
एक्सप्लोर जरूर कीजिए। खुद से कीजिए। इट्स
अ गुड हैबिट। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बट स्टिल इससे बढ़िया प्लेटफार्म नहीं है।
अब मैं आपको एक-एक चीज इसका ना ब्रेकडाउन
करके बताऊंगा। ऐसा नहीं है कि मैं बस इसके
क्वेश्चन सॉल्व करके और आपकी और आपको
बोलूंगा हो गया भाई खत्म हो गई ये। ऐसा
नहीं है। मैं आपको ब्रेकडाउन कर करके
एक-एक चीज सिखाऊंगा। एक-एक चीज बताऊंगा और
आपको पूरी चीजें समझाऊंगा। एक-एक चीजें
कैसे काम करती है और साथ में हम हैंड्स ऑन
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन करेंगे क्योंकि इसमें बहुत
कुछ है। बहुत सारी नई-नई चीजें आपको पता
चलेंगी। आपको ऐसीऐसी चीजें पता चलेंगी जो
आपने आज तक शायद नहीं जानी होंगी। साथ ही
में इसमें प्रीमियम रूम्स हैं कुछ उनको भी
हम देखेंगे क्योंकि ऑब्वियस सी बात है कुछ
लोगों के पास या बहुत लोगों के पास ट्राई
हैक में प्रीमियम नहीं होता है एंड इस वजह
से वो प्रीमियम रूम सॉल्व नहीं कर पाएंगे
या उनके बारे में नहीं जान पाएंगे। तो हम
वो सारी चीजें देखेंगे। बट मेरा मेन जो
फोकस है वो है इन कॉम्प्लेक्स चीजों को
ब्रेकडाउन करके आपको समझाना। तो प्लीज
ध्यान दीजिएगा इधर। मजा आने वाला है आपको
आज की क्लास में। आपको फिशिंग एनालिसिस
इसलिए सीखना है क्योंकि आप इसके बिना शॉक
एनालिस्ट कहला ही नहीं सकते हैं। आप इसके
बिना शॉक एनालिस्ट के लिए अगर जाते हैं
इंटरव्यू [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
देने तो आप शायद वहां पे आपको दिक्कत आ
सकती है। जैसे मैंने बोला था मैथ्रे
फ्रेमवर्क हो गया आपका। साइबर किलचेन हो
गया। यूनिफाइड किलचेन जो था वह हो गया। अह
यह सारी चीजें पिरामिड ऑफ पेन जो था। इन
सब चीजों के अलावा के बिना आप स्टॉक
एनालिस्ट नहीं कह सकते अपने आपको। यू डोंट
डिर्व टू बी कॉल्ड अ शॉक एनालिस्ट। अगर
आपको ये चीज नहीं पता है तो प्लीज इन
चीजों को कांसेप्ट को ध्यान दीजिएगा और
पूरी तरीके से कंज्यूम कीजिएगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] चलिए हम यहां
पे फिशिंग एनालिसिस के कुछ फंडामेंटल्स
पहले देखने वाले हैं। बट उसके लिए यहां पे
सिंपल सा पहले ही आ रहा है सेट अप वर्चुअल
एनवायरमेंट। अब क्या है ये वर्चुअल
एनवायरमेंट? हम उसको भी समझेंगे। फिलहाल
के लिए हम एक चीज को स्टार्ट करते हैं
यहां से। स्पैम एंड फिशिंग रिमेंस द मोस्ट
कॉमन सोशल इंजीनियरिंग थ्रेट्स फेसिंग
मॉडर्न ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। मॉडर्न ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
पे सबसे ज्यादा अगर कोई थ्रेट काम करती है
वो फिशिंग सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
कहलाती है। सबसे ज्यादा फिशिंग के जो है
अटेमप्ट्स देखने को मिल जाते हैं। किसी भी
तरह के ऑर्गेनाइजेशन पे। फिशिंग हो गई,
रैंसमवेयर हो गया। ये सब बहुत ज्यादा
देखने को मिलते हैं। ठीक है? अब एज
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अ डिफेंडर योर
रोल इनवॉल्व्स एनालाइजिंग ईमेल
कॉम्पोनेंट्स। तो जब आप एक एसओसी शॉक
एनालिस्ट एल1 होते हैं तो आपका एक मेन रोल
होता है कि आप ईमेल कॉमोनेंट्स को एनालाइज
करो। यह बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट पार्ट है एंड इट
शुड बी डन बाय शॉक एनालिस्ट्स। ये आपका
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट काम है। टू डिटरमाइन इफ
दे आर मलशियस और बिनिंग एंड गैदरिंग
इंफॉर्मेशन टू हेल्प हार्ड एंड सिक्योरिटी
मेजर्स अगेंस्ट फ्यूचर अटैक्स। फ्यूचर
अटैक से आपको जो है वह बचाती है अगर आप
अच्छे से एनालिसिस कर पाते हैं क्योंकि
कोई भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के ऊपर जब एक बड़ा
अटैक होता है जब एक जब एक कंबाइंड अटैक
होता है तो जब इस तरह की जब अटैक्स होती
है ना तो उसमें मल्टीपल चीजें इंक्लूडेड
होती है। चेस चेस होते हैं। मल्टीपल चीजें
को मिला के एक
जो है वो कोलाइडेड एक अटैक किया जाता है।
अब उन अटैक्स में फिशिंग का सबसे बड़ा रोल
है। क्योंकि फिशिंग एक ऐसी चीज है जिसके
थ्रू आप उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के एंप्लाइज को
टारगेट कर सकते हैं और उनके थ्रू ही
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर कर सकते हैं। उनके थ्रू
ही इनफार्मेशन निकाल सकते हैं। दिस इज़ द
पावर ऑफ़ फिशिंग। बेसिकली इट इनवॉल्व्स
यूजिंग सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक्स। हम
उसके बारे में भी सब जानेंगे। मजा आएगा
आपको। देखिए अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे एक स्टार्ट मशीन करने को बोल रहा
है। तो हम यहां पे एक मशीन स्टार्ट कर
देते हैं। लैब मशीन है। इसको हमने यहां से
स्टार्ट कर दिया। ये बड़ा नहीं होगा क्या?
फुल स्क्रीन में नया टैब में खुल जाएगा।
ठीक है? चलिए तो हमने एक नया मशीन ये
स्टार्ट कर दिया। यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं है।
चेक हम यहां पे चेक कर देते हैं। ठीक है?
फाइन। अब यहां पे आते हैं सबसे पहले ईमेल
एड्रेस के ऊपर में। ठीक है? ईमेल एड्रेस
में एग्जैक्टली क्या है? एव्री फिशिंग
ईमेल यू विल इन्वेस्टिगेट। हर फिशिंग ईमेल
जो आप इन्वेस्टिगेट करेंगे हर फिशिंग ईमेल
एड्रेस
स्टार्ट्स विद समथिंग सिंपल वो एक मतलब
सिंपल ईमेल से स्टार्ट होता है एन ईमेल
एड्रेस राइट ईमेल एड्रेस होती है इफ यू
डोंट अंडरस्टैंड हाउ इट्स स्ट्रक्चरर्ड यू
मे ओवरलुक द वेरी क्लोज अटैकर्स रिलाई ऑन
ठीक है ईमेल एज वी नो टुडे वाज़
पॉपुलराइज़्ड इन 1970 ईमेल को पॉपुलराइज़
किया था 1970 में ऑन आरपानेट बाय रे टॉम
लिंसन इन्ह इन्होंने इसको पॉपुलराइज किया
था आरपनेट पे ठीक है हु इंट्रोड्यूस द @
सिंबल उन्होंने ही @ सिंबल को इंट्रोड्यूस
किया था जो क्या करती थी यूजर को सर्वर से
डिफरेंशिएट करती थी यूजर को सर्वर से जैसे
अब ई आप क्या करते हैं लाइक ईमेल एड्रेस
कैसा होता है जैसे मेरा नाम हुआ या
difronic@gmail.com
ऐसा हुआ तो डिफ्रॉनिक्स एक यूजर हो गया और
सर्वर आपका gmail यानी Google की सर्वर हो
गई तो उसको डिफरेंशिएट करता था हमारा ये @
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब देखिए सो व्हाट्स मेक अप एन ईमेल
एड्रेस मेकअप ईमेल एड्रेस में क्या-क्या
चीजें होती हैं एक यूजरनेम होता है जैसे
डेविड ये एक यूजरनेम हो गया एक @ सिंबल ये
@ और एक डोमेन नेम होता है जो कि लास्ट
वाला आपका होता है वो डोमेन नेम कहलाता
है। ठीक है? तो जब भी कोई ईमेल आपको आती
है तो सबसे पहले आपको यह जरूर चेक करना
चाहिए कि एक्चुअली वो डोमेन एग्जिस्ट करती
भी है कि नहीं करती है। राइट? अगर मान लो
मैं मैं ऐसे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
मान लो लेट्स सपोज़ मैं यहां पे एक ईमेल एक
ईमेल आईडी है नितेश @ ये किया
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ये ईमेल आईडी है। अब ये ईमेल आईडी
एक्चुअली एकिस्ट कब करेगी? जब यह
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन @ के बाद वाला डोमेन यह
एग्जिस्ट करता है। अगर यह वैलिड नहीं है,
एग्जिस्ट नहीं करता है, इसका मतलब यह ईमेल
आईडी फर्जी ईमेल आईडी है। दिस कुड बी अ
स्पैम मलिशियस और अ फिशिंग ईमेल। दैट्स
इट। सबसे पहला हमारा तरीका तो यही हो जाता
है इसको पहचानने का कि भैया यह एक वैलिड
ईमेल आईडी के लिए वैलिड डोमेन होना बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। सिंपल। चलिए, आगे
की तरफ हम बढ़ते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यह एग्जांपल वही है जो इन्होंने समझाया।
अब यहां पे क्या आ रहा है? आइडेंटिफाई द
डोमेन यूज्ड इन द फॉलोइंग एड्रेस। इसमें
डोमेन कौन सा है? बताइए मुझे। सभी लोग
बताइए इसमें डोमेन क्या है? बहुत ईजी आंसर
है इसका। लेट मी नो। डोमेन क्या है इसमें?
इस ईमेल आईडी में बताइए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एवरीवन हैव टू आंसर इट।
व्हाट इज द डोमेन इन दिस?
किसी को ये डोमेन नहीं पता। हां, ठीक है।
द डोमेन इज़ सिंपल ट्राई.com।
तो, हम यहां पे tryatm.com करके आगे बढ़
जाते हैं। दिस वाज़ वेरी सिंपल। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हां, डोमेन को आप ब्राउज़र के अंदर भी डाल
के चेक कर सकते हैं। या आप वायरस टोटल पे
भी डाल सकते हैं। वायरस टोटल पर जब आप
जाएंगे देखिए। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][हंसी]
ये वायरस total.com है। यहां पे आप वायरस
टोटल पे जब जाएंगे तो आप जैसे कि यहां पे
अगर कोई यूआरएल है आपको तो यूआरएल स्कैन
कर सकते हैं। सर्च पे जाएंगे तो आप यहां
पे डोमेन डाल सकते हैं। कोई सा भी डोमेन
तो मैंने अगर डाला यहां पे dfonx.com
और मैं अगर यहां पे सर्च करूंगा तो ये उस
डोमेन के बारे में डिटेल बताएगा कि भैया
क्या यह डोमेन कोई सिक्योरिटी अह लाइक
रिस्क है? किसी तरह का मशियस डोमेन है या
फाइन ओके है तो आप यहां पे इस तरीके से
जाके इसको चेक आउट भी कर सकते हैं और वो
डोमेन एक्सिस्ट भी करना चाहिए एक्सैक्टली
एक्सिस्ट करना चाहिए तभी वो वैलिड डोमेन
कहलाएगा [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ईमेल
डिलीवरी पे आते हैं। अब देखो जब भी आप
ईमेल सेंड करते हैं तो बहुत सारे
प्रोटोकॉल्स जो है ना वो आप ईमेल सेंडिंग
के पीछे काम कर रहे होते हैं जब भी आप
ईमेल सेंड करते हैं। ठीक है? अब हां अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देखो कुछ कुछ
वेबसाइट टेम मेल को रिजेक्ट कर देती है वो
डोमेन चेक करती है। अब देखो जैसे टेम मेल
की बात यहां पे कर रहे हैं कोई कि जैसे
टेम मेल में भी कुछ डोमेनस यहां पे आपको
मिलते हैं। अब जैसे मेरे को मैंने टेम
मेलजी खोला। अब यहां पे कोई एक डोमेन
जनरेट होती है। हम इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं
और इसको वायरस टोटल में हम देखते हैं। ठीक
है? हमने क्या किया? वायरस टोटल में डाला
और यहां पे हमने इसको सर्च कर लिया। अब
देखो ये करेगा। तो यहां पर क्या है कि
इसके पास अभी कोई करंट इसके पास कोई इसका
रिजल्ट नहीं है। अगर मैं यहां पर डोमेन
इसको डालूं और मैं सर्च करूं तो यहां पे
आएगा कि मेरे पास कोई रिजल्ट नहीं है।
इसका इसका मतलब ये है कि दो चीजें हो सकती
है। या तो ये डोमेन एकिस्ट नहीं करती है।
या तो ये डोमेन जो है वो एक टेंपरेरी
डोमेन है जो डेटाबेस में नहीं प्रेजेंट है
और इसकी कोई भी सिग्नेचर कुछ है नहीं। तो
ये टेंपरे टेंप डोमेन होते हैं और बहुत
सारी वेबसाइट्स इन डोमेनस को एक्सेप्ट
नहीं करती है वो इसलिए ताकि स्पैम ना हो
टेंपरेरी डोमेनस को और उसको जब भी आप
टेंपरेरी डोमेन यूज़ करोगे तो बेसिकली क्या
होगा कि वो यूज़ में नहीं अच्छा सॉरी मैंने
तो पूरा ही कॉपी कर दिया था। मैं यहां पे
डोमेन को कॉपी कर लेता हूं इस डोमेन को। अ
चलो मैंने पूरा ही डाल दिया था शायद।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मैंने ईमेल ही
डाल दिया था। उम् डोमेन को कॉपी करते हैं
और डोमेन को एंटर करते हैं। अब इस पे आ
जाएगा। तो डोमेन को हमने कॉपी किया। यह
क्लीन है। बिलकुल ओके है। तो अगर ऐसा आता
है तो यह डोमेन एग्ज़िस्ट तो करता है और ये
मलशियस भी नहीं है। डिपेंड करता है। और
अगर कुछ भी नहीं आता कुछ अगर कुछ रिजल्ट
भी नहीं आता तो भी वहां पे सस्िशियस वो हो
सकता है। बट यहां पे ये सस्िशियस नहीं है।
कोई सिक्योरिटी वेंडर ने इसको फ्लैग नहीं
किया है। और दिस इज़ ओके डोमेन। बट क्योंकि
ये टेंपरेरी डोमेन है तो बहुत सारी
वेबसाइट जो है अपने पोर्टल पे टेंपरेरी
डोमेन का जो है एक्सेस वो टेंपरेरी डोमेन
का यूज़ जो है डिसेबल करके रखते हैं फॉर
स्पैम पर्पस स्पैम वगैरह से बचने के लिए।
ठीक है? तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जब
आप मेल सेंड करते हैं तो यहां पे बहुत
सारे प्रोटोकॉल्स काम करते हैं। उसमें से
तीन इंपॉर्टेंट प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं। जैसे एक
है एसएमटीपी, दूसरा है पॉप 3, तीसरा है आई
मैप। तो एसएमटीपी ईमेल सेंड करने के लिए
यूज़ में लिया जाता है। ईमेल जब आप सेंड
करते हो जो आपका पॉप थ्री है जिसको हम
पोस्ट ऑफिस प्रोटोकॉल बोलते हैं। एसएमटीपी
का फुल फॉर्म आपको पता होगा। सिंपल मेल
ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल बहुत लोग पढ़ते हैं
इसके बारे में। पॉप थ्री हो गया पोस्ट
ऑफिस प्रोटोकॉल। पोस्ट ऑफिस प्रोटोकॉल
क्या करता है? डाउनलोड ईमेल्स टू अ
डिवाइस। यह एक डिवाइस पे ईमेल्स वगैरह को
डाउनलोड करने के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता
है। सिंगल डिवाइस पे। ठीक है? और आईmप
क्या करता है? इंटरनेट मैसेज एक्सेस
प्रोटोकॉल यह ईमेल्स को मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस
पे सिंक्रोनाइज करने के लिए यूज़ में लिया
जाता है। जैसे अगर आपने अपने फोन पे ईमेल
लॉगिन किया आपने वही ईमेल लैपटॉप पे लॉगिन
किया। किसी और फोन पे लॉग इन किया तो सिंक
हो जाते हैं ना आपके ईमेल्स। राइट? तो वो
सिंकिंग का काम का ये आई मैप होता है कि
यहां भी वही ईमेल दिख रहा है। वहां भी वही
ईमेल दिख रहा है। सब कुछ बराबर-बराबर। तो
वो सिंकिंग का काम करता है। व्हेन
रिसीविंग ईमेल्स योर ईमेल सर्विस यूजसेस
आइदर पॉप 3 और आई मैप डिपेंडिंग ऑन हाउ
योर मेल बॉक्स इज़ कॉन्फ़िगर्ड। जैसे आपका
मेल बॉक्स कॉन्फ़िगर्ड है उसके अकॉर्डिंग
एक सिंगल डिवाइस के लिए पॉप 3 यूज़ हो
जाएगा। मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस के लिए आई मैप
यूज़ हो जाएगा। तो POP थ्री क्या है?
ईमेल्स आर डाउनलोडेड एंड स्टर्ड ऑन अ
सिंगल डिवाइस। popp 3 में ईमेल्स सिंगल
डिवाइस पे डाउनलोड स्टोर होते हैं। सेंट
मैसेजेस आर स्टर्ड ऑन अ सिंगल डिवाइस।
इसमें भी सेम मतलब सिंपल सा आप समझिए कि
पॉप 3 के केस में सिंगल डिवाइस पे सब कुछ
होता है। एवरीथिंग हैपेंस ऑन सिंगल
डिवाइस। डाउनलोड होती है ईमेल्स। मैसेजेस
सेंट और जो होते हैं वो स्ट होते हैं।
ईमेल्स एक्सेस आप सिंगल डिवाइस से कर सकते
हैं। और ईमेल्स टिपिकली क्या हो जाता है?
रिमूव्ड आफ्ट फ्रॉम द सर्वर आफ्टर
डाउनलोड। मतलब डाउनलोड के बाद उन ईमेल्स
को बेसिकली रिमूव कर दिया जाता है सर्वर
से। आईmप में क्या हो जाता है? बेसिकली कि
यह स्टर्ड किए जाते हैं मतलब सर्वर पे जो
भी ईमेल्स होते हैं और उसको आप मल्टीपल
डिवाइसेस से डाउनलोड वगैरह कर सकते हैं।
सेंट मैसेजेस जो होते हैं वो भी सर्वर पे
स्टोर किए जाते हैं। सिंक्रोनाइज मैसेजेस
जो है मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस से आप एक्सेस कर
सकते हैं और ईमेल जो है वो सर्वर पे ही रह
जाते हैं अगर आपने डिलीट नहीं किया है। यह
बस दोनों में अंतर है। थैंक यू वेरी मच यश
यश यशवीर सिंह।
ठीक है? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये सारी
चीजें दोनों में डिफरेंस है। अब ईमेल की
जर्नी एक्सजेक्टली क्या होती है? ये चीजें
देखो मैं आपको ये चीजें क्यों बता रहा
हूं? मैं आपको क्लियर कट बता रहा हूं। अगर
आपको ऐसा लगता होगा कि अरे सर ये तो क्या
ही टॉपिक है सर इतना इंपॉर्टेंट थोड़ी ना
होगा। तो ये आपकी गलतफहमी है। मैं पहले
बता दे रहा हूं। बाद में प्लीज मुझे ब्लेम
मत कीजिएगा आप लोग कभी भी कोई भी आके कि
सर आपने इस टॉपिक के बारे में डिटेल में
बताई नहीं या फिर सर आपने यह नहीं बोला कि
यह इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक था। हम तो गए थे
इंटरव्यू में। ने हमसे इसी हमसे तो ईमेल
फिशिंग के बारे में क्वेश्चन पूछ लिया।
हमसे पूछ लिया एनी रन क्या होता है? एनी
रन में कैसे एनालिसिस करते हैं? बहुत सारी
चीजें हो सकती हैं। तो सब चीजें हम
पढ़ेंगे बस। ठीक है? तो प्लीज ध्यान
दीजिएगा इधर। आई रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू
फोकस ऑन हियर। ठीक है? रादर दैन ईमेल
जर्नी की क्या होती है? ईमेल। ईमेल जर्नी
कैसे काम करता है? देखते हैं। कैसे ईमेल
वर्क करता है? तो पहले यूजर सेंड्स एन
ईमेल। सबसे पहले द सेंडर्स ईमेल क्लाइंट
जो सेंडर्स ईमेल क्लाइंट है जैसे मैं एक
सेंडर हूं और मैं अपने दोस्त को एक ईमेल
सेंड कर रहा हूं तो मेरा जो क्लाइंट है
जैसे मैं Google का Gmail का यूज़ कर रहा
हूं Gmail ऐप वो क्लाइंट ऐप हो गया सेंड्स
द मैसेज टू देयर मेल सर्वर यूजिंग sएमटीp
अब Gmail जो है अपने मेल सर्वर मान लो मेल
सर्वर mailg.com है तो उसको वो क्या करेगा
मैसेज भेजेगा किसका यूज़ करता है एसएमटीपी
का सिंपल मेल ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल का उसके
बाद मेल सर्वर क्वेरी क्वीज़ द डीएनएस। अब
मेल सर्वर जो है डीएनएस को क्वरी करेगा
डोमेन ने सिस्टम को। ठीक है? क्या
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] करेगा? द
सेंडिंग सर्वर आस्क डीएनएस फॉर द
रिसिपिएंट डोमेनस मेल सर्वर। अब डीएनएस से
ये पूछेगा कि भैया ये जो मैसेज जाना है तो
जिसके पास जाना है उसका मतलब मेल सर्वर
बताओ मुझे। उसकी मुझे दो आईपी दो भाई।
किसको भेजना है, क्या भरना है। उसको मुझे
बताओ उसके बारे में कि किसको भेजना है।
डीएनएस को क्वरी करेगा। डीएनएस का काम
आपको पता ही है डोमेन एंड सिस्टम को।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डीएनएस रिस्पांस डीएनएस रिटर्न्स द एड्रेस
ऑफ द रिसिपिएंट्स मेल सर्वर। अब डीएनएस
क्या करता है? जो मैं अपने दोस्त को भेज
रहा हूं तो मेरे दोस्त के मेल सर्वर का
आईपी एड्रेस निकाल के दे देगा कि भैया इसी
आईपी पे आपको भेजनी है मेल। लो मेरा काम
खत्म। ईमेल इज़ डिलीिव। अब जब आईपी आ गई,
ईमेल डिलीवर हो जाता है। मैसेज सेंड
अक्रॉस द इंटरनेट टू रिसीपिंट सर्वर। ईमेल
चली गई। द रिसिपिएंट चेक्स देयर मेल
बॉक्स। अब मेरा दोस्त मेल बॉक्स को चेक
करेगा। अपने किसके क्लाइंट जो सॉफ्टवेयर
है उसका Gmail अपना Gmail जो होगा उससे
चेक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] करेगा उसके
मेल सर्वर से वो ईमेल आ गई ईमेल इज
रिट्रीव्ड द मैसेज इज़ डाउनलोडेड पॉप थ्री
और सिंक्ड आई मैप टू द रिसिपिएंट डिवाइस
अब मैसेज या तो डाउनलोड हो जाएगी पॉप 3
उसमें यूज़ हो जाएगा एंड अगर सिंक हो रही
है तो आई मैप यूज़ हो जाएगा इस तरीके से
पूरा का पूरा ये ईमेल का सिस्टम काम कर
रहा होता है एक ईमेल आप सेंड करते हैं ये
छह स्टेप्स जो है उसमें हो रहा होता है
बैक एंड में आपका एसएम टीपी पॉप 3 आई मैप
जैसे प्रोटोकॉल्स काम कर रहे होते हैं। ये
पूरा जर्नी हो गया। चलिए
क्वेश्चन [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आंसर्स
की बारी आ गई है। मैं आपके साथ ही करूंगा।
आपको भी मजा आएगा ताकि प्लीज फोकस कीजिएगा
और जल्दी-जल्दी आंसर कीजिएगा। प्लीज डोंट
डिले इन आंसरिंग। फटाफट व्हिच प्रोटोकॉल
इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर सेंडिंग एन ईमेल फ्रॉम
अ क्लाइंट टू मेल सर्वर? बताइए। फटाफट
बताइए कौन सा प्रोटोकॉल रिस्पांसिबल होता
है? जल्दी बताइए। एवरीवन मुझे आंसर चाहिए।
आई एम सीइंग द आंसर। जल्दी बताइए फटाफट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
प्लीज टेल मी गाइस एवरीबडी आई एम सीइंग
रिस्पांस
[हंसी]
चलिए बहुत लोग बोल रहे हैं इसमें इसमें
बहुत लोगों का रिप्लाई है एसएमटीपी चलिए
एसएमटीपी बिल्कुल सही आपका रिस्पांस है
एसएमटीपी करेक्ट व्हिच सर्विस इज़ यूज्ड टू
लुक अप द रिसिपिएंट डोमेनस मेल सर्वर वि
सर्विस इज़ यूज्ड टू लुक अप द रिसिपिएंट
डोमेनस मेल सर्वर जो मेरे दोस्त है उसके
मेल सर्वर के अ
के बारे में पता करने के लिए कौन सी
सर्विस यूज़ होती है? डीएनएस। बहुत सही बात
है। क्या बात है यार। बड़ा जल्दी आंसर कर
रहे हो तुम लोग।
डीएनएस बिल्कुल [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सही। बॉब वांट्स टू एक्सेस ह ईमेल फ्रॉम
मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस इंक्लूडिंग हज़ फोन एंड
लैपटॉप। व्हिच प्रोटोकॉल शुड ही यूज़? कौन
सा प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ होगा? बॉब मल्टीपल
डिवाइसेस एक्सेस करना चाहता है ईमेल?
बताइए।
[हंसी]
एक ने बोला है मिस्टर इलियट ने आई मैक
गलती से शायद टाइप हो गया होगा आई मैप
बिल्कुल सही बात है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आई मैप बिल्कुल
सही मतलब आपको समझ में आ रहा है इतना तो
मुझे पता चल चुका है दैट्स वेरी वेरी गुड
बहुत बढ़िया अब आते हैं ईमेल हेडर्स को
समझते हैं। देखिए ये ईमेल हेडर जो है बहुत
ज्यादा बहुत ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग है गाइस।
आपको इसको समझना पड़ेगा। ईमेल हेडर्स जो
है ईमेल हेडर्स के थ्रू आप बहुत कुछ कर
सकते हैं। आप जो इन्वेस्टिगेशन वगैरह करते
हैं वो इन्वेस्टिगेशन में भी ये हेल्प
करती है। काफी ज्यादा हेल्प करती है। इवन
साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन में भी इसका
बहुत बड़ा रोल है। ईमेल हेडर
इन्वेस्टिगेशन के अंदर आपको आते हैं। तो
ईमेल हेडर्स को समझते हैं। ईमेल में दो दो
चीजें होती है। एक ईमेल हेडर होता है और
एक ईमेल बॉडी होती है। एक ईमेल हेडर होता
है और एक ईमेल बॉडी होती है। ठीक है? अब
मैं आपको इस चीज को वैसे दिखाने की कोशिश
करता हूं। अगर मेरे पास यह चीज ओपन होगी
और कुछ ऐसा ना हो तो। एक सेकंड मैं देख
लेता हूं।
हम चलिए तो मैं यहां पे आपको एक नॉर्मल सा
ईमेल दिखाता हूं कोई सा भी। जैसे एक ये
ईमेल हो गई। ईमेल आईडी खुल गई। अब मान लो
यहां पे ये एक ईमेल आया Asian Paints का।
राइट? ये ईमेल हो गई। ये ईमेल हो गया।
राइट? तो अब इसमें दो ही फील्ड्स होते
हैं। एक इसका क्या होता है? एक इसका होता
है हेडर होता है ईमेल का। ठीक है? और एक
होता है बॉडी। हेडर में अलग-अलग तरह की
इंफॉर्मेशन होती है। जैसे कि ईमेल कहां से
आया है? ठीक है? ईमेल किसको भेजा गया है?
ठीक है? या ईमेल जो है उसका रिप्लाई टू
एड्रेस क्या है? सब्जेक्ट क्या है? डेट
क्या है? ये सारी चीजें ईमेल हेडर में
होती है। और बॉडी में ईमेल का कंटेंट होता
है। जो भी कंटेंट होता है मैसेज का जो भी
चीजें भेजी जाती है, वह पूरा का पूरा
कंटेंट होता है। बस यही होता है आपका ईमेल
हेडर्स। अब देखिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ईमेल हेडर में ईमेल बॉडी वो होती है। ईमेल
हेडर की अब बात करते हैं तो हेडर में
देखते हैं। तो हेडर में जैसे कि आप कोई
ईमेल ओपन करते हैं तो हेडर में कुछ इस
तरीके की होती है। किस तरीके से? फ्रॉम टू
रिप्लाई टू सब्जेक्ट डेट ये सारी फील्ड्स
वगैरह होती है। अब हमारे पास जो वीएम है,
आई थिंक यह ओपन हुआ है कि नहीं हुआ है?
क्या हो गया? इसको मैं इसको रीलोड कर लेता
हूं। इसको ओपन कर लेते हैं।
कनेक्टिंग
फेल्ड टू कनेक्ट। ऐसा क्यों भाई?
चलो इसको बंद करते हैं।
चलो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इसको
टर्मिनेट करके वापस से एक बार ओपन कर लेते
हैं। आई थिंक कुछ कुछ इशू होगा शायद
क्योंकि तभी तो मजा आएगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
गेट इट
लेट इट ओपन वंस [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
एक्सपेंडेड व्यू में खोल देते हैं इसको।
ठीक है? यहां पे ओपन हो रहा है हमारा लेट
इट ओपन। ठीक है? उसमें आपको दिखाऊंगा। तब
तक इधर देख लेते हैं। कुछ इस तरीके से
होती है। फ्रॉम टू रिप्लाई टू सब्जेक्ट।
ये आपका हेडर होता है। ठीक है? ये नॉर्मल
सी हेडर हो गई। तो चलिए अब यहां पे हेडर
में आप क्या-क्या चीजें कर सकते हैं वो भी
देखते हैं। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इसको ओपन हो जाने देते हैं।
ट
इस वाली क्लास के लिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हो सकता है कि
आपके दो पार्ट्स हो इस क्लास का। शायद
थोड़ी बड़ी हो जाए। मतलब इस वजह से
ओके चलिए यह ओपन हो गया।
परफेक्ट परफेक्टली ओपन हो गया। यह क्या हो
गया? कुछ दिख क्यों नहीं रहा है यार
इसमें?
ओके। फेल टू कनेक्ट टू सर्वर। कुछ तो
प्रॉब्लम है इनका।
देयर इज सम इशूज़।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इनके साइड से इशू है। होता रहता है इनको।
इनके इश्यूज होते रहते हैं। कोई बड़ी बात
नहीं है। ऐसे कैसे काम चलेगा भैया?
अब इसको हम वैसे तो एक्सेस कर सकते हैं।
फिर वही वीपीए वगैरह कनेक्शन वगैरह
का करना पड़ेगा। टाइम लग जाएगा उसमें।
इसको यह ओपन क्यों नहीं हो रहा है?
आई थिंक ट्राई हैक मी के सर्वर का इशू है
यह। इट्स नॉट इट्स नॉट एन इशू ऑफ आवर साइड
ट्राई हैक में इशू सर्वर साइड इशू फिर से
एक बार ट्राई कर लेते हैं लास्ट
बताओ यार ऐसे थोड़ी ना होना चाहिए
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
मैंने ऐसे चेक किया था सही था सब कुछ बट
अभी आई डोंट नो व्हाई इट्स नॉट ओपनिंग
लेट्स ट्राई
अच्छा आपको भी प्रॉब्लम आई थी मतलब
ट्राईगमी के साइड से कुछ दिक्कत है क्या?
आपको भी इशू आ रहा है मतलब ट्राईगमी के
साइड से ही है।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
अरे भाई ओपन तो हो तब तो एक 3 मिनट सेटअप
के लिए यूज़ करेंगे हम। पहले ओपन तो हो
जाए।
चलिए अभी तो लग रहा है ओपन हो हुआ है इधर।
आई डोंट नो इट विल पॉपुलेट ऑ नॉट।
स्टिल नॉट गेटिंग हियर एनीथिंग।
हां। चलिए आर्या। फाइनली आ चुका है हमारा।
नाउ इट्स
ओपन। हां ओपन हो गया। चलिए अब यहां पर आ
जाते हैं ईमेल हेडर्स में। अब यहां पे ये
बोल रहा है कि आप भाई ईमेल 1ML फाइल ओपन
कर लेते हैं। तो ईमेल सैंपल्स में ईएमएल
जो है फाइल फर्स्ट वाला इसको हम ओपन कर
लेते हैं ताकि हम इसमें अच्छे से देख
पाएंगे। राइट? तो वी हैव ओपन इट। लेट्स
सी।
यह ओपन हो चुका है। यहां पर हमारे पास कुछ
इस तरीके की ईमेल की यह ओपन हो चुकी है।
यह ईमेल है। अब यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं
यह हेडर जो है उसमें ये फ्रॉम हो गया
एड्रेस जहां से आ रहा है टू एड्रेस हो गई
यहां से। ये रिप्लाई टू है। सब्जेक्ट है
ये सारी चीजें। साथ ही में अगर आप इसका
सोर्स देखना चाहते हैं जैसे कि व्यूविंग
मैसेजिंग सोर्स। तो इस ईमेल एड्रेस का
कंप्लीट सोर्स देख सकते हैं। और उसमें भी
बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
जो चीजें हैं
बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट चीज होती है। व्यू
पर चलते हैं। मैसेज सोर्स यहां पे यह
ऑप्शन होगा। या तो कंट्रोल यू प्रेस करके
भी आप इसको ओपन कर सकते हैं। इसको जब ओपन
करेंगे तो यह सोर्स है मैसेज का। यह
एग्जैक्टली क्या बताता है आपको? इस ईमेल
के बारे में कंप्लीट इसका फुटप्रिंट आपको
देता है। कंप्लीट फुटप्रिंट। बहुत सारी
डिटेल्स, अटैचमेंट्स के बारे में, फ्रॉम
टू आईपी एड्रेस बहुत सारी चीजें। रियल
आपको Gmail में अगर ये चीजें देखनी है तो
आपको Gmail में जो ईमेल आई है इस पे यहां
पे ऑप्शन होता है और यहां पे शो ओरिजिनल
करके ऑप्शन मिलेगा। इस पे जब आप क्लिक
करेंगे तो आपको यही जो पर्टिकुलर आपको ये
जो रॉ फॉर्मेट है आपका ये सोर्स जो है
उसकी पूरी डिटेल जो है आपको यहां पे देखने
को मिल जाती है। इसमें कंप्लीट आपको डिटेल
कंप्लीट सारी चीज़ आपको यहां पे ये वाली
आपको दिख रही होगी। आपको वो सारी डिटेल्स
होती है। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। अब आगे की तरफ चलते हैं। अब यहां पे
आ रहा है व्हाट इज द फुल सब्जेक्ट लाइन ऑफ
ईमेल 1ML? तो ये बहुत आसान क्वेश्चन है।
देयर इज़ नथिंग
एंड कुछ बहुत बड़ी चीज नहीं है। तो
सब्जेक्ट क्या है? तो भैया सब्जेक्ट ये
है। हेल्प प्रोटेक्ट योर बजट बाय
प्रोटेक्टिंग होम। ये सब्जेक्ट है। हम
इसको डाल देते हैं यहां पे। हो गया। दैट्स
इट। सिंपल। तो इस तरीके से आप ईमेल के
सोर्स को ओपन कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? मैसेज
सोर्स को। अब आते हैं हमारे कि एक और
क्वेश्चंस पे। व्यू द मैसेज सोर्स ऑफ़ ईमेल
ईएमएल वन यूजिंग द ठीक है? व्यू करना है।
व्हाट इज़ द IPपी एड्रेस लिस्टेड एक्स
ओरिजिन IPपी। अब इसमें IPपी एड्रेस भी
बताता है। जैसे मैंने आपको बोला। तो हमें
क्या करना है? व्यू पे करना है। मैसेज
सोर्स पे जाना है। और हमें IPपी एड्रेस
देखना है। तो अब IP एड्रेस में एक्स
ओरिजनेटिंग IPपी यहां पे आपको हेडर मिल
जाएगी। ये हेडर मिल जाएगी। इसमें आपको IP
एड्रेस लिस्टेड मिल जाती है। एक्स ओरिजिन
IPपी यह आपको मिल जाती है। रिसीव्ड फ्रॉम
IP यहां पर आपको मिल रही है। राइट? तो अब
यहां पे हम एक्स ओरिजनेटिंग IP को कॉपी
कर लेते हैं जो हमारा क्वेश्चन है। राइट?
हमने यहां पे पुट किया, चेक किया। [संगीत]
ठीक है? ये हमने कर लिया।
ठीक है? गॉट इट? अब यहां पे समझ में आ गया
आपको? ये क्लियर है? सिंपल सा है। फंडा
खत्म। अब ईमेल बॉडी की बात आते हैं। अब
ईमेल बॉडी में क्या है कि ईमेल बॉडी में
सिंपल सा है कि जो मैसेज आपको आ रहा है
वही होता है। उसमें आपके टेक्स्ट हो सकते
हैं, अटैचमेंट्स हो सकते हैं, इमेज हो
सकता है, कुछ भी हो सकता है। जैसे कि मुझे
यह मैसेज आया राइट? मुझे ये मैसेज आया
कहां से? Asian Paints की तरफ से। अब इस
मैसेज में ये जो मैसेज मुझे मिल रहा है
जिसमें कि ये इन्होंने एक इमेज डाला है।
इन्होंने एक कांटेक्ट फॉर्म डाल दिया है।
दिखा ये कांटेक्ट फॉर्म यहां पे आपको डी
लाइक कुछ नीचे में कुछ एक इमेज डाल दिया
है। ये सारी चीजें डाल दी है। तो ये जो
चीजें हैं ये जो चीजें मिल रही है। जैसे
मैं इस पे क्लिक करूंगा तो देखो अभी क्लिक
करके कहां मैं रीडायरेक्ट हो जा रहा हूं।
इनके पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट पे रीडायरेक्ट हो
जा रहा हूं। अगर मैं इनके इस पर्टिकुलर
इमेज पे क्लिक कर रहा हूं तो मैं यहां पे
अगेन इनके वेबसाइट पे रीडायरेक्ट हो रहा
हूं। तो मतलब एक इमेज है और इसके अंदर एक
यूआरएल छुपा हुआ है। तो ये यूआरएल आपको
कैसे पता चलेगा? आप इस इमेज के ऊपर में
माउस को हवर करेंगे। यहां पे ऐसे ही माउस
का कर्सर ले जाएंगे तो नीचे की तरफ यहां
पे यहां पे इस बॉटम में लेफ्ट में सबसे
नीचे लेफ्ट साइड में आपको उसका यूआरएल
देखने को मिल जाएगा। इसका आईएमजी सोर्स भी
आपको इसका लिंक भी मिल जाएगा। कैसे
मिलेगा? देखो बॉटम पे यहां पे लिंक पे
क्या है? ई लिंक आई एनc ma मैप मेलर asियन
pins.com ऐसे मिल रहा है। इस पे जाएंगे तो
ये लिंक पे जा रहे हैं आप। इस लिंक पे
फोकस आप जा रहे हैं। अब यहां पे हम शो
ओरिजिनल करते हैं। शो ओरिजिनल पे करेंगे।
हम इसका व्यू सोर्स देखेंगे। राइट? अब जब
आप सोर्स देखेंगे तो आपको सोर्स में बहुत
सारी चीजें देखने को मिलेगी। हम उस पे अभी
और भी डिस्कस करेंगे। बट हमें लिंक चाहिए।
तो लिंक जो होता है वो जनरली एचआरएफ टैग
जो होती हैं उसमें आपको मिलता है। एचआरएफ
टैग जो होती है तो एचआरएफ सर्च करेंगे तो
आपको सोर्स में इस ईमेल के सोर्स में आपको
लिंक मिल जाएगा कि उस इमेज के पीछे क्या
लिंक है। अब वो कैसे? तो देखो यहां पे
आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पे। सिंपल सा दिख
रहा है यहां पे। टेक्स्ट कोड यहां पे दिया
हुआ है। टेबल विड्थ वगैरह ये तो एचटीएमl
की है। टी टीआर टीडी। ठीक है? यहां पे
क्लोज़र और यहां पे आपको दिख रही होगी कि
टीडी क्लास जो है यहां पे एक बनी हुई है
जो वो बैनर है।
बैनर जो आपको बैनर यहां पे देखने को मिल
रहा है। सेंटर [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
में अलाइन है। अब इसमें जो एएआरएफ लिंक है
यानी जो लिंक जिस पे ये रीडायरेक्ट कर रहे
हैं वो आपको यहां देखने को मिलेगी।
hटीएमएल में एचआरएफ का एक टैग होता है
जिसमें आप लिंक्स को डिफाइन करते हैं। तो
ये लिंक आपको देखने को मिल रहा है। और इसी
लिंक पे हम एक्चुअली रीडायरेक्ट हो रहे
हैं। ये जो लिंक है अगर आप कॉपी करते हैं
इस लिंक को। ये देखो ये लिंक है ये बड़ी सी
यहां से लेके यहां से लेके यहां से लेके
देख रहे हो ये यहां से लेके यहां से लेके
ये ये पूरा एक लिंक है ये है पूरा यूटीएम
सोर्स ये यहां यूटीएम तक का ये ये पूरा
आपका लिंक हो गया अब इस लिंक को मैं कॉपी
करके अगर मैं इसको ओपन करने की कोशिश
करूंगा तो यह मुझे Asian Paints के
वेबसाइट पे लेकर चला जाएगा। राइट? ये मतलब
रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है। बेसिकली ये
रीडायरेक्शन लिंक है जो कि आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे। इसलिए आपको ये अभी इस तरीके
से ओपन नहीं हो रही है क्योंकि यहां पे
क्या है? ये रीडायरेक्ट कर रही है। कहां
पे रीडायरेक्ट कर रही है? इस वाले लिंक्स
पे। ये एक ये तो एक जिफ लिंक है। इस पे
नहीं कर रही है आपकी। बट ये रीडायरेक्ट
आपको कर रही है Asian Paints के ऑफिशियल
वेबसाइट पे जो इसका ऑफिशियल वेबसाइट है।
सिंपल। तो अगर मैं मान लो यह HTPS यह ले
लो क्लाइंट आईडी इक्वल टू दिस देन। एंड
अगर मैं इसको पूरा ही कॉपी कर लेता हूं।
फुल इसको मैं कॉपी कर लेता हूं। और इसको
अगर ओपन करने की कोशिश करते हैं तो आपके
इस Asian Paints के वेबसाइट पे रीडायरेक्ट
कर देगा। उस टाइम मैंने पूरी लिंक कॉपी
नहीं करी थी। आधी करके ओपन कर दिया था। इस
वजह से ओपन नहीं हुई थी। बट स्टिल यहां पे
हमने पूरा लिंक कॉपी कर दिया। जो भी लिंक
था यहां तक और हमने इसको यहां पे पेस्ट
किया। तो हमारी एसिन पेंट्स वाली जो उस
इमेज पे क्लिक करके जो लिंक रीडायरेक्ट हो
रहा था वही सेम चीजें यहां पे रीडायरेक्ट
हम हो चुके हैं। तो ये लिंक के बारे में
आपको बताते हैं। तो एचआरएफ सर्च करके आप
लिंक्स को देख सकते हैं कि भैया कौन सी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लिंक्स चलिए फिर
से ये वही ट्राईकमी का वही नाटक हो गया।
ठीक है कोई बात नहीं अभी के लिए दिक्कत
नहीं है। बट पता नहीं देयर इज़ सम काइंड ऑफ़
इशू आई थिंक। चलिए ये तो आपने देख लिया।
अब यहां पे बॉडी में क्या होगा? बॉडी में
यहां पे क्या-क्या चीजें होती हैं?
अटैचमेंट से रिलेटेड अगर कोई अटैचमेंट है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] उससे रिलेटेड
डिटेल्स आपको देखने को मिल जाएंगे। ठीक
है? जैसे कि यहां पे कंटेंट टाइप इसमें
आपको कंटेंट टाइप देखने को मिल जाएगा कि
क्या कंटेंट टाइप यूज़ हो रहा है। लाइक कोई
पीडीएफ है, कोई डॉक्यूमेंट है, किस तरह का
डॉक्यूमेंट है। कंटेंट डिस्पोज़शन
स्पेसिफाई दैट द फाइल इज़ एन अटैचमेंट एंड
इंक्लूड्स इट्स फाइल नेम। यह बताएगा कि
फाइल एक अटैचमेंट है और इसका एक फाइल नेम
इंक्लूडेड है। कंटेंट ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
ये बताता है कि ये कंटेंट में किसी तरह का
इनकोडिंग यूज़ हो रहा है कि नहीं। जैसे बेस
64 हो गया या जीजीप हो गया। किसी भी तरह
का इनकोडिंग तो वो इनकोडिंग के बारे में
आपको यहां पे सब कुछ बताएगा। ठीक है?
सिंपल फंडा। अब यहां पे आप देखेंगे कि जो
हमारे पास अभी ये ट्रायकमी की ईमेल जो ओपन
हुई थी, इसमें क्या है कि एक पीडीएफ
अटैचमेंट इंक्लूडेड है। देयर इज़ एन पीडीएफ
अटैचमेंट। ठीक है? अब इस पीडीएफ अटैचमेंट
के बारे में डिटेल्स यहां पे आपको यह दिखा
रहा होता। तो अब यहां पे आपको अभी देखते
हैं फिर से यह क्या हो रहा है भाई।
अगेन ट्राइंग टू
स्टार्ट
लेट्स सी।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सम इशूज़ गन गोइंग वि द
मी
स्प्लिट। सो बाहर निकल जाते हैं। यहां से
डायरेक्ट यहीं से देखते हैं ओनली।
लेट्स सी इफ इट इज वर्किंग और नॉट
देयर सम ट्राईक साइड इशज़
अच्छी लाइन बोली है। डिफॉनिस इज़ द बिगेस्ट
स्कैम एवर दे स्कैम यू इंटू लविंग साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। अच्छी बात है भाई। पहले तो
तुम हार्ट अटैक दे दिए लेकिन दूसरी लाइन
में तुमने उसको बढ़िया कर दिया। गुड।
भाई ये हो क्या रहा है यार? वीpए का यूज़
करना पड़ेगा क्या? बट फिर भी वीpए का भी
यूज़ करने का कोई फायदा नहीं है क्योंकि
इनका सर्वर इशू है। तो अगेन सेम हम एक्सेस
नहीं कर पाएंगे उसको।
बहुत टाइम ले खा रहा है यह तो हमारा।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
लेट्स सी
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग
बहुत अच्छी बात है। सीबू भट्टा
वेलकम टू द डिफ्रॉनिक्स।
क्या हो रहा है यार? ट्रैक मी वालों का ये
क्या नाटक है यार? ये हद है।
प्लेटफार्म गड़बड़ हो रही है क्या इनके?
फेल टू कनेक्ट टू सर्वर देख रहे हो इनका
इशू है यह इनका सर्वर ही कनेक्ट नहीं हो
पा रहा है इसमें क्या करें यार बताओ
हम वीpए से भी कनेक्ट करके अगर इसको
स्टार्ट करते हैं ना तो भी कोई फायदा नहीं
है क्योंकि इनका ही सर्वर इशू है तो हम
वीpए से भी कनेक्ट करेंगे तो उसका वही है
सर्वर को ही कनेक्ट कर रहे हैं ना इनके तो
अरे रिफ्रेश तो कई बार कर दिया भाई। एक
बार थोड़ी ना मैं तो हार्ड रिफ्रेश
कंट्रोल आर करके भी कर रहा हूं। कई बार
रिफ्रेश कर दिया बट उससे हो नहीं रहा।
देखते हैं एक बार और करके
क्योंकि ये चीजें समझाने के लिए
इंपॉर्टेंट है। ये इसका ओपन होना। आपको
थोड़ा अच्छे से समझ में आएगी ऐसी चीजें
क्लेरिटी के साथ।
अरे भैया ऐसे तो कैसे होगा?
अरे यार टर्मिनेट करो यार। टर्मिनेट करो
वापस से चालू करो।
बंद है यार।
हम
अगेन लेट्स स्टार्ट
[कराहने की आवाज़]
नहीं यहां देखो अपन तो कोई सा भी वो यूज़
कर सकते हैं। बट यहां जो
चीजें जिस तरीके से मैं चाहता था आपको
बताना ना वो चीजें यहां पे है। अवेलेबल
है। तो मैं चाहता हूं आपको ये चीजें
सिखाना है। ये चीजें मैं आपको थोड़ा सा
एक्सप्लेन करना चाहता हूं। इसमें अभी एक
चीज ये तो अभी नॉर्मल सा आप देख रहे हो।
अभी हम आगे बढ़ेंगे तो इसमें बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें आने वाली है जो आपका
दिमाग खोल के रख देंगी। वो मैं चाहता हूं
यहां से आपको समझाना। मैं अब देखते हैं
फिर क्या होता है यार।
क्या करें अब?
चलो स्पिट व्यू से बाहर आके यहां पे ही कर
लेते हैं। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग।
वेरी गुड इवनिंग।
देखो अभी भी यह कनेक्ट अभी शायद अभी शायद
ओपन हो जाएगा शायद। मुझे ऐसा लग रहा है इट
विल ओपन नाउ। मुझे अंदर से ऐसी फीलिंग आ
रही है कि इट शुड ओपन नाउ।
यह क्या सीन है यार? टर्मिनेट करने के बाद
ओपन हो जा रहा है। फिर थोड़ी देर बाद गायब
हो जा रहा है।
आजा सिम सिम
इस बार मैंने मंत्र मारा है। आजा अरे यार
क्या बात है देखा ये कमाल है मंत्र का।
चलो [अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
अब यहां पे आ गए हैं। ईमेल बॉडी के अंदर आ
रहे हैं। ठीक है? ये बॉडी होती है आपकी।
सिंपल सा फंडा है यहां पे। अब यहां पे
बॉडी में डिटेल्स होते हैं। ईमेल जो
एक्चुअल ईमेल होता है उसकी पूरी डिटेल
होती है। अब यहां जैसे कि मैंने ओपन कर
लिया है। जो फाइल है उसको ओपन कर लेते
हैं। ईमेल वन वाली फाइल ही ओपन कर लेते
हैं। राइट ये वाली फाइल ओपन कर लेते हैं।
यस यू आर बैक। कहां थे?
अच्छी [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बात है।
आई एम रोहित। वेरी गुड। सो इट्स ओपन नाउ
हियर।
ठीक है? इट्स ओपन। अब यहां पे देखो यहां
पे एक इसमें इनके कहने का मतलब है
ये फाइल है यहां पे। अब देखो यहां पे
लेट्स कंपेयर द रेंडर वर्जन ऑफ़ ईमेल वन
ईएम वन। ईमेल वन जो ईएमएल है मैसेज एंड
इट्स अंडरलाइन HTML। ठीक है? यू मे नोटिस
द अब यहां पे क्या है ना? दिस अलाउ अस टू
सी द रॉ HTML दैट रेंडर्स द मैसेज। मतलब
कि ये मैसेज रेंडर करता है जो बेसिकली रॉ
HTML जो आपको है यहां पे देखने को मिल
जाएगा जो भी चीजें यहां पे देखने वाली है
इमेज वीडियो जो इमेज वगैरह जो भी है सारी
चीजें देखने को मिल जाएगी अब देखो ईमेल्स
कैन आल्सो इंक्लूड अटैचमेंट सच ऐ
डॉक्यूमेंट्स इमेजज़ फाइल टाइप्स ईटीसी ठीक
है तो ईमेल्स में सब कुछ हो सकता है एज़ द
ईमेल बॉडी कैन बी एनालाइज़ बाय व्यूंगिंग द
मैसेज सोर्स ईमेल बॉडी को आप मैसेज सोर्स
से एनालाइज़ कर सकते हो जैसे हम जा रहे थे
यहां पे व्यू पे जाके और मैसेज सोर्स देख
के एनालाइज़ कर रहे थे अटैचमेंट्स कैन बी
एनालाइज़्ड एज वेल अटैचमेंट्स को भी हम
एनालाइज़ कर सकते हैं। ठीक? ठीक है? इन द
एग्जांपल बिलो यू विल सी एन एचटीएमएल
फॉर्मेटेड
अ ईमेल कंटेनिंग अ पीडीएफ डॉक्यूमेंट। ठीक
है? यह पीडीएफ डॉक्यूमेंट एक ईमेल कंटेन
करता है। द रेंडर व्यू शोज़ द अटैचमेंट एज़
इट अपीयर्स इन द ईमेल क्लाइंट। यह रेंडर्ड
इसका व्यू है। व्हाइल द सोर्स व्यू शोज़ अह
मतलब यह बेसिकली रेंडर्ड है और यह सोर्स
वाला है। द हाउ इट इज़ एक्चुअली स्टर्ड विद
इन द मैसेज। ठीक है? व्हेन वी इंस्पेक्ट द
सोर्स वी कैन आइडेंटिफाई सेवरल इंपॉर्टेंट
हेडर्स। हमारे को अलग-अलग हेडर्स देखने को
मिलते हैं। जैसे कंटेंट टाइप जो इसका उस
पर्टिकुलर अटैचमेंट का कंटेंट का टाइप
बताता है। ये सब मैंने आपसे डिस्कस कर
लिया है। द इनकोडेड बेस 64 दैट फॉलोज़
रिप्रेजेंट द फाइल इटसेल्फ। दिस डेटा कैन
बी डिकोडेड टू रिकंस्ट्रक्ट द ओरिजिनल
फाइल यूजिंग ये टूल्स साइबर शेफ के होते
हैं। अब यहां पे क्या करते हैं? ओपन द
ईमेल 2.txt अब ईमेल टू ओपन करना है। चलिए
तो हमने ईमेल टू को ओपन कर दिया।
यहां से हम ईमेल 2.txt ओपन कर रहे हैं
क्योंकि ये टीxt फाइल है। आप देख सकते हैं
यहां पे। अब यहां पे आ रहा है व्हाट इज द
कंटेंट टाइप ऑफ द अटैचमेंट? अब इसमें
बताइए इसमें कंटेंट टाइप क्या है? कंटेंट
टाइप क्या है इसमें? सभी लोग बताइए। व्हाट
इज द कंटेंट टाइप हियर?
एवरीबॉडी प्लीज आंसर इस
ईमेल 2.txt फाइल में जो कि यहां पे आपको
दिख रहा होगा। इसमें कंटेंट टाइप क्या है?
यस करेक्ट। कंटेंट टाइप इज़ एप्लीकेशन
पीडीएफ। ये हमारा कंटेंट टाइप है। तो, हम
यहां पे कंटेंट टाइप डाल देते हैं और चेक
कर लेते हैं। ठीक है? गुड। व्हाट इज द नेम
ऑफ़ द अटैचमेंट फ्रॉम द प्रीवियस क्वेश्चन?
अब नेम अटैचमेंट का नाम क्या है? तो आपको
देखो यहां पे अटैचमेंट का नाम दे रखा है
जे एम क्यू पी ए एल जी एच डॉट pdf तो हमने
अटैचमेंट का नाम यहां पे फाइल नेम के अंदर
में अटैचमेंट का नाम दिया हुआ है। तो हमने
अटैचमेंट का यहां पे नाम भी मेंशन कर
दिया। ठीक है? [संगीत]
डिकोड द बेस 64 स्ट्रिंग यूजिंग पीडीएफ
कन्व्टर और साइबर शेफ। व्हाट इज द हिडन
फ्लैग वैल्यू? अब देखो तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे आपको
बोला जा रहा है कि आपको बेस 64 स्ट्रिंग
को डिकोड करना है। तो देखो बेस 64 इन कौन
सा स्ट्रिंग है? ये ये जो यहां जे वी से
स्टार्ट हो रहा है ना और लास्ट तक वो सारे
बेस 64 इनकोडिंग है। ये जो नीचे तक आप
आएंगे यहां पे नीचे आ जाओ। नीचे आ जाओ।
लंबा सा यहां पे है ये।
यहां तक लास्ट में यह 0k तक यहां तक यह
नीचे वाली नहीं है। यह नहीं है। यहां तक
यह बेस 64 इनकोडिंग्स है। अब इसको डिकोड
करना है। तो इसके लिए हमें पहले ये पूरा
इनकोडिंग जो है इसको हमें कॉपी मारना
पड़ेगा। देखो मैं यहां पे कॉपी मारता हूं।
लेट्स कॉपी इट। लेट्स कॉपी इट।
मैंने यहां से यहां तक की ये पूरी की पूरी
कॉपी कर ली और इसको हमें डिकोड करना है।
तो डिकोड करने के लिए बेसिकली हम साइबर
शेफ जैसे प्लेटफार्म का यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
दिस इज़ अ गुड प्लेटफार्म फॉर डिकोडिंग एंड
ऑल। तो मैं साइबर शेफ पे चलता हूं। अब
हमें बेस क्या करना है? बेस 64। तो किसको
डिकोड करना है? बेस 64 यानी कि फ्रॉम बेस
64 ये वाला हमारा जो है रेसिपी इसको यूज़
करना है फ्रॉम बेस 64। ठीक है? तो फ्रॉम
बेस 64 हमने इसको टिक कर दिया। हमने इसको
यहां ला दिया है। अब हमें इनपुट में वो
बेस 64 वाली जो हमने कॉपी करी थी उसको
डालते हैं।
चलो ये इनपुट में आ गया। यहां पे ये इनपुट
आ गई। अब यहां पे आप देखोगे कि आउटपुट में
आपको कुछ मिला देखने को नहीं है। यहां पे
कुछ देखने को यहां पे आउटपुट में तुम्हें
कुछ यहां मिल नहीं रहा है। अजीब तरीके की
चीज़ लिखी हुई है। तो इसका तरीका है आपको
क्या करना है? इसको फाइल को सेव करना है
आउटपुट फाइल को। तो मैं इसको सेव करता हूं
और डाउनलोड पीडीएफ ये ऑप्शन से सेव हो रहा
है। तो मैं इसको यहां पे सेव करता हूं।
सेव करने के बाद डाउनलोड पीडीएफ नाम की एक
फाइल डाउनलोड हो जाएगी। अब इस पीडीएफ को
ओपन कर लेते हैं। इस पीडीएफ को जैसे ही
ओपन करेंगे आपको यहां पे फ्लैग मिल जाएगा।
का टीएचएम बेनिग पीडीएफ अटैचमेंट ये आपका
बेसिकली फ्लैग है। तो इस तरीके से थोड़ा
सा दिमाग लगाना पड़ता है। तो आप सिर्फ सोच
रहे हैं कि बेस 64 को डिकोड करके और बस हो
गया यहां पे आपको आउटपुट में देखने को मिल
जाएगा डिकोड करके स्ट्रिंग का सीधा ये
आपको ये मिल जाता तो ऐसा नहीं था। आपका जब
फाइल इसको डाउनलोड करनी थी और फाइल के
अंदर वो कोड जो है आपको मिल जाता। तो
हमारे पास इसका भी फ्लैग आ चुका है। हमने
यहां पर डाला और हमने यहां पे इसको सॉल्व
कर दिया है। सिंपल
बट ये सिंपल अभी इतना जल्दी खत्म नहीं
होगा। अभी ये चीजें और कॉम्प्लेक्स होती
जाएंगी। जैसे-जैसे हम आगे बढ़ेंगे देखते
हैं। लेट्स सी। अब आते हैं टाइप्स ऑफ
फिशिंग के ऊपर में। लेट्स कम टू द टाइप्स
ऑफ़ फिशिंग। देखो
अब हमें फिशिंग का बेसिक आईडिया थोड़ा हो
गया है। तो अब हमें टाइप्स ऑफ फिशिंग पे
आते हैं। फिशिंग के बहुत सारे टाइप्स होते
हैं। डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ़ मलेशियस ईमेल्स
कैन बी क्लासिफाइड एज़ वन ऑफ़ द फॉलोइंग।
अलग-अलग टाइप्स होते हैं। जिसमें से एक
होता है स्पैम, एक फिशिंग, एक स्पेयर
फिशिंग, एक वेलिंग, स्मिंग एंड विशिंग। अब
इसका मतलब समझते हैं। स्पैम का मतलब है
बल्क ईमेल्स। किसी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] को भेजा जा रहा
है, अनवांटेड ईमेल्स आ रहे हैं तो स्पैम
होते हैं। एज सिंपल एज दैट। तो अगर कोई
मलिशियस स्पैम [हंसी] है यानी एक ऐसा
स्पैम जो मलशियस फॉर्म में हो उसको हम मैल
स्पैम बोलते हैं। मैल स्पैम मलिशियस स्पैम
को उसके बाद आती है बारी नॉर्मल फिशिंग
की। तो इसके बारे में आपको पता है ईमेल्स
दैट इंपपर्सनेट अ ट्रस्टेड एंटिटी टू
ट्रिक रेसिपिएंट्स इनू रिवेलिंग सेंसिटिव
इनफेशन। सिंपल ऐसे ईमेल्स जो ट्रस्टेड
ब्रांड्स ट्रस्टेड ऑर्गेनाइजेशन ठीक है?
ट्रस्टेड पीपल इन लोगों की मिमिक करता है।
इन लोगों की इमपर्सोनेशन करता है। उनको
डुप्लीकेट डुप्लीके डुप्लीकेसी करता है
उनकी और इसलिए ताकि सेंसिटिव इनफेशन
निकाला जाए सके। उसे फिशिंग बोलते हैं।
स्पियर फिशिंग एक ऐसा फिशिंग ये फिशिंग ही
होता है जो एक टारगेटेड फिशिंग होती है।
किसी एक पर्टिकुलर इंडिविजुअल के अगेंस्ट
या एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अगेंस्ट जहां पे
पर्सनलाइज्ड इनेशन का यूज़ किया जाए। जैसे
मैं एक इंडिविजुअल हूं या मेरी कंपनी है
तो मेरे बारे में कुछ पर्सनलाइज इनेशन
गैदर किया गया अटैकर की तरफ से और मेरे
ऊपर अटैक किया गया फिशिंग का वो स्पेयर
फिशिंग कहलाता है। वेलिंग जब हम किसी हाई
लेवल एग्जीक्यूटिव्स को टारगेट करते हैं
जैसे किसी कंपनी का सीटीओ है, किसी कंपनी
का सीएमओ है, सीएफओ है, सीओ है, सीईओ है
तो उनको हम वेलिंग बोलते हैं। हाई लेवल
एग्जीक्यूटिव है तो उनके लिए थंब भी अलग
होना चाहिए यार। वेल्स को पकड़ रहे हैं।
मतलब समझ रहे हो? वेल्स बड़ी मछली स्मिंग
हम एसएमएस के द्वारा टेक्स्ट मैसेज के
द्वारा जो फिशिंग करने की कोशिश की जाती
है मोबाइल डिवाइस के ऊपर वो स्मिंग कहलाता
है और विशिंग जो हम फोन कॉल्स के थ्रू
आपको फिशिंग के अटैक्स देखने को मिलते हैं
वो विशिंग कहलाते हैं जिसमें सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का यूज़ किया जाता है और फोंस
पे आपको सामने वाला बंदा इमपर्सनेट करता
है कि मैं बैंक से हूं या मैं फलाना से
हूं ढिकाना से हूं अलग-अलग ट्रस्टेड
एंटिटी के तरफ से वह बोल के आपसे से
इंफॉर्मेशन लेने की कोशिश करता है। तो दिस
इज़ नोन एज फिशिंग। अब फिशिंग ईमेल का अगर
हम एनाटॉमी समझे तो क्या है? व्हेन इट
कम्स टू फिशिंग अटैकर्स ऑफेन रिलाई ऑन
सिमिलर टेक्निक्स रिगार्डलेस ऑफ देयर गोल।
एक सिमिलर टेक्निक होता है। उस पे रिलाई
करते हैं। सम बिलो आर द सम कॉमन
कैरेक्टरिस्टिक्स ऑफ़ फिशिंग ईमेल्स। मतलब
आपको कुछ कैरेक्टरिस्टिक्स यहां पे देखने
को मिल रहा है जो फिशिंग ईमेल का
कैरेक्टरिस्टिक्स है। मतलब इस तरह की चीज
आपको देखने को मिले अगर ईमेल के अंदर तो
समझिए कि ये एक तरह का फिशिंग ईमेल हो
सकता है। प्रोबेबिलिटी बहुत ज्यादा हाई
है। सबसे पहले आता है स्पूव्ड फ्रॉम
एड्रेस फ्रॉम एड्रेस। जैसे कि ये जो आपको
दिख रहा है यहां पे
यह।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओरिजिनल इसी में दिखा देता हूं मेरे वाले
में। ठीक है? फ्रॉम एड्रेस में जैसे यह एक
फ्रॉम एड्रेस है। राइट? तो अब यह फ्रॉम
एड्रेस जो है अगर यह किसी तरह का स्पव्ड
एड्रेस है। मतलब कि फ्रॉम एड्रेस में आपको
यहां तो Asian Paints दिख रहे हो। दिख रहा
हो कि Asian Paints है जो भेजा है मेल को।
बट अंडर का यूआरएल किसी और ही डोमेन का
हो। XYZ.com
है ना? तो वो एक स्पूव्ड फ्रॉम एड्रेस
होगा। ऐसा चीज आपको मिले देखने को तो वो
डाउटफुल होगा। मलेशियस हो सकता है।
अर्जेंट सब्जेक्ट और मैसेज अब कोई ऐसा
ईमेल आया जहां आपको एकदम तुरंत अर्जेंसी
दिखाया जा रहा है कि आपका जो है एलपीजी
कनेक्शन बंद कर दिया जाएगा अगर आपने ये
नहीं किया। आपकी इलेक्ट्रिसिटी कनेक्शन कट
कर दी जाएगी अगर आपने ये नहीं किया। आपका
अकाउंट लॉक कर दिया जाएगा अगर आपने यह
नहीं किया। आपका अकाउंट ब्लॉक कर दिया
जाएगा। डीएक्टिवेट कर दिया जाएगा अगर आपने
यह नहीं किया। आपका बैंक अकाउंट फ्रीज कर
दिया जाएगा क्योंकि आपके बैंक अकाउंट में
एक
एक मशियस या मतलब एक फेक ट्रांजैक्शन या
कुछ इस तरीके की ट्रांजैक्शन मलेशियस
ट्रांजैक्शन हुई है सस् ट्रांजैक्शन हुई
है उसके बेस ये अर्जेंसी दिखाया जा रहा है
तो जब अर्जेंसी दिखाया जाए किसी भी मेल
में किसी भी ईमेल के अंदर में वहां पे
आपको डाउट करना है उसके ऊपर में ब्रांड
इंपर्सनेशन
कि अगर कोई बड़े-बड़े ब्रांड की
इंपपर्सनेशन कर रहा है अब जैसे मान लो कोई
डिफ्रॉनिक्स का लोगो लगा के डिफ्रॉनिक्स
की मैचिंग कलर्स नई स्कीम यूज़ कर लिया,
लोगो लगा लिया और उसी से आपको मेल करने
लगा तो आपको लगेगा अरे यह तो डिफ्रॉनिक्स
का मैसेज आया हुआ है और उससे आपको स्कैम
किया जाए तो आपको तो लगेगा डिफ्रॉनिक्स ये
चीजें हो रही है डिफ्रॉनिक्स के साइट से
करिए बट आपको वहां पे ईमेल का जो हेडर है
जो ईमेल का मैसेज सोर्स है कंप्लीट उसको
पढ़ना है देखना है कि सोर्स आईपी
एक्सैक्टली क्या है किस डोमेन से भेजा जा
रहा है क्या यह डोमेन एक्चुअली
डिफ्रॉनिक्स की है वो सब आपको
इन्वेस्टिगेट करना है और तब आपको एक्चुअल
पता चलेगा
एक इससे रिलेटेड एक मैचिंग आपको मैं आपको
एक इंसिडेंट बता देता हूं। कोई एक बंदा था
Instagram पर। उसने बहुत सारे स्पैम किए
हमारे Instagram के कमेंट्स वगैरह में
ऐसा-ऐसा क्यों किया उसने? पता है क्यों?
जब
मैंने उससे बात की, पूछा कि भाई यह सब
क्या कर रहे हो? कोई मतलब तो है नहीं। तो
उसका रिप्लाई है कि सर
आपने
मेरे से कितने
कुछ ऐसे ही बोल रहा था 101000 या कुछ ऐसे
अमाउंट था आपने मेरे से ले लिया है आपने
मुझे स्कैम किया है ऐसा मैसेज आया था उसका
मैसेज आज भी रखा है मैंने Instagram पे तो
मैंने बोला अच्छा मैंने स्कैम किया तो
बताओ क्या स्कैम किया है मतलब किस तरीके
से किया है तो आप आपका कॉल आया था आपने
बोला यह कोर्स है वो कोर्स 10,000 में
मिलता है आपने मुझे एक्सेस नहीं दिया और
उसके पैसे भी मैंने आपको भेज दिए हैं।
मेरे पास सारी प्रूफ्स हैं। मैंने बोला
अरे वाह यार मैं 10,000 का स्कैम हो गया।
मेरे पास पैसे नहीं आए और इसने स्कैम भी
मुझे बोला कि स्कैम कर दिया। मैंने बोला
तो शेयर करो डिटेल्स शेयर करो। क्या है
क्या है? तो उसने एक्चुअल में ट्रांजैक्शन
की डिटेल्स वगैरह शेयर की और नंबर भी
भेजे। दो नंबर भेजे। दोनों नंबर में से
कोई सा भी नंबर हमारा नहीं था। और जो
ट्रांजैक्शन उसने किए उसने किसी और यूपीआई
आईडी पे किया है जिसने डिफ्रॉनिक्स नाम
यूज कर लिया मतलब एक यूपीआई आईडी कोई भी
नाम आप क्रिएट कर सकते हैं यूपीआई हैंडल
यूपीआई आईडी से उसने डिफ्रॉनिक्स के नाम
से बना के इसको चिपका दिया था इसने
पेमेंटमेंट कर दिया होगा ये हो गया
स्कैम्ड अब जब नंबर मैंने देखा तो ये नंबर
किसी और का था रैंडम और फेक नंबर्स होंगे
या कुछ भी होंगे जो भी व्हाटएवर तो मैंने
उसको समझाया कि भाई ये जो सारी चीजें हैं
तुम्हें स्कैम किया गया है। इसलिए तुम्हें
लग रहा होगा कि मैं हूं तुम्हें मेरे
प्रोफाइल से गया था क्या मैसेज? तो बोल
रहा है नहीं आपके नहीं लेकिन आप ही का एक
और प्रोफाइल है उससे गया था और उसका एक वो
फेक प्रोफाइल थी जिससे उसको मैसेज गया था।
अब मैंने उसको बोला कि जाओ पुलिस कंप्लेन
करो अगर तुम्हें ऐसा लगता है ऐसेवैसे तो
वो बोलता है कि आप अपनी आवाज रिकॉर्ड करके
भेजो क्योंकि उसने मेरे से कॉल पे बात की
थी। मैंने उसको आवाज भी रिकॉर्ड करके भेज
दी। सोचो करना पड़ता है कभी-कभी। उसके बाद
भी वह बंदा असोर नहीं है। वह बोल रहा है
कि मुझे अभी भी डाउट है। लग तो नहीं रहा
आप हो। आपकी आवाज अलग है। बट डाउट तो
मैंने बोला भाई तुम जाओ कंप्लेंट डालो
साइबर सेल में पुलिस डिपार्टमेंट में सब
कुछ करो। बोलोगे तो मैं भी आ जाऊंगा
तुम्हारा साथ देने। पता करो। वो बंदा शक
में रह गया। ऐसी चीजें होती हैं
इंपर्सोनेशन होती है और ऐसा आइडेंटिटी
थफ्ट भी होता है इंपपर्सनेशन होती है
चीजें होती है जो एक्चुअली आपको प्रॉब्लम
में डाल सकती है रियली प्रॉब्लम में
एक्चुअल प्रॉब्लम में डाल सकती है आपको तो
इस तरीके की चीजों से बचने के लिए आपको
इन्वेस्टिगेशन आना चाहिए आपको समझ में आना
चाहिए एक्सैक्टली किस तरीके की चीजें काम
करती है कैसे होता है बस दैट्स इट राइट यस
लाइक कर दो सभी लोग ग्रामर एंड स्पेलिंग
इशूज़ आपको जो फिशिंग ईमेल्स आएंगे उसमें
आपको ग्रामेटिकल एरर्स और स्पेलिंग एरर्स
देखने को ज्यादातर मिलने के चांसेस होते
हैं। आपको वहां देखने को मिलेंगे।
जेरिक कंटेंट द मैसेज लैक्स पर्सनलाइजेशन
डियर कस्टमर इंस्टीड ऑफ योर नेम जनरिक
मैसेज होगा। डियर कस्टमर हे कस्टमर हेलो
कस्टमर आपका नाम नहीं होगा स्पेसिफिक
क्योंकि वो मल्टीपल लोगों को भेज रहे होते
हैं। एक जो है एक कंबाइंड अटैक होता है
मल्टीपल लोगों पे। तो वो सोचते हैं कि अरे
यार एक-एक करके कैसे हो सकता है? तो सब
डाल दो ऐसे [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हिडन और शॉर्ट एंड लिंक्स शॉर्ट एंड
लिंक्स का यूज़ करते हैं ताकि एग्जैक्टली
इस तरीके का सिक्योर लॉग इन ऐसा ताकि आपको
एग्जैक्ट पता ही ना चले कि उस शॉर्ट एंड
लिंक के पीछे रियल लिंक क्या है। हालांकि
उस पे हो करेंगे आपको पता चल जाएगा। कई
लोग उतना नहीं ध्यान देते लिंक पे क्लिक
कर देते हैं। मलेशियस अटैचमेंट मलेशियस
अटैचमेंट्स ऐड कर देते हैं। कोई भी पीडीएफ
डॉक्यूमेंट या किसी भी तरह का डॉक्यूमेंट
हो सकता है। उसको ऐड कर देते हैं। कुछ इस
तरीके का आपको देखने को मिलेगा यहां पे।
पे आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे जो ईमेल आई है
फ्रॉम क्लाउड स्टोरेज टीम ट्रस्टेड सेंटर
है लेकिन इसका ईमेल जो है ईमेल आईडी यह
देखिए यह अजीब सा ईमेल आईडी आपको देखने को
मिल रहा है यह एक मलशियस ईमेल आईडी यहां
पे है जिसे भेजा जा रहा है कुछ इस तरीके
से अर्जेंसी दिखाई जा रही है योर अकाउंट
विल बी लॉक्ड विद इन 48 आवर्स योर स्टोरेज
कैपेसिटी इज़ फुल रिसीव 50 GB वाह ऐसे ही
50 GB ले लो तो यह इस तरीके से काम करती
है अब यहां पे एनालिसिस के उस पे अब कैसे
इस चीज़ को हम थोड़ा सा सही कर सकते हैं?
व्हेन डीलिंग विथ हाइपरलिंक्स एंड
अटैचमेंट्स बी केयरफुल नॉट टू क्लिक देम
एक्सीडेंटली। कोई भी लिंक पे हाइपरलिंक्स
पे क्लिक नहीं करना चाहिए। जनरली
हाइपरलिंक्स एंड आईपी एड्रेसेस शुड बी
डिफेंग्ड। डिफेंग्ड। डिफेंग्ड का मतलब
होता है कुछ इस तरीके का। जैसे कि मान लो
कोई एक
अ लाइक वो है
डोमेन मतलब ईमेल किसी तरह का कोई लिंक है
कोई भी लिंक है जैसे मान लो https
colon dfonics.com अब ऐसी ईमेल जब आएंगी
मे ईमेल में तो यूजुअली क्या होगा अ
यूजुअली क्या होगा कि ये क्लकेबल होता है
गलती से भी क्लिक हो सकती है तो इसको
डिफाइन किया जा सकता है डिफाइन का मतलब है
कि एसटीपीएस ले लो इसके बाद यहां पे ऐसे
या ऐसे करके इसको ऐसे करके ब्रैकेट में
डाल दो। फिर इस पर्टिकुलर
के जगह पे भी यहां पे ब्रैकेट यूज़ कर लो।
मतलब इसको चेंज कर देना। इसका अ जो
लुक लुक है, इसका जो व्यू है वो ऐसा कुछ
कर देना जो क्लिककेबल ना हो। बट एक्चुअल
मतलब उसका वही हो। तो उसको हम डिफेंग्ड
बोलते हैं। ठीक है? क्लिककेबल से हटा
देना। जैसे कि अगर कोई ओरिजिनल ईमेल आईडी
कुछ इस तरीके से है http colon wwws
susspics domin.com तो डिफेंड होने के बाद
कुछ इस तरीके से यह आपको देखने को मिलेगी।
इसको हम डिफेंड्ड यूआरएल बोलते हैं। इसी
तरीके से IPपी एड्रेस को भी डिफाइन किया
जा सकता है। किसी भी तरह की लिंक्स को,
यूआरएल्स को, IPपी एड्रेस को डिफाइन किया
जा सकता है। ठीक है? इसके भी प्लेटफार्म
होते हैं। मैं आपको बताऊंगा कैसे करना है।
चलिए अब इस नॉलेज का यूज़ करते हैं। ईमेल 3
को ओपन करते हैं और क्वेश्चंस के आंसर
देते हैं। तो चलिए यहां पे मैं इसको क्लोज
कर देता हूं। ईमेल थ्री को मैं मेल ओपन कर
देता हूं। चलो यह ओपन हो चुका है। ईमेल 3
कुछ इस तरीके से क्या है? व्हिच रेपिटेबल
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन इज़ बीइंग स्पव्ड इन दिस
फिशिंग अटेम्प्ट। इसमें कौन सा रेपिटेबल
एक रेपिटेबल जो यह क्या खुल गया भाई? इसको
बंद करो। कंपनी है जिसको कि यह टारगेट
किया जा रहा है। तो देखो फ्रॉम जो देखो
थैंक यू होम डिपोर्ट मतलब यह मेल कहां से
आई है? थैंक यू अगर यहां पे होम डिपोर्ट
की जगह Netflix लिखा रहता तो यानी कि यह
मेल Netflix के तरफ से आई है। तो यह होम
डिपोर्ट नाम के कंपनी से आई है। तो यहां
पे टारगेट हो रहा है होम डिपोर्ट। यह
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है जो जिसका जिसको मिमिक
किया जा रहा है। बेसिकली
सही है। होम डिपोर्ट राइट। व्हाट इज द
सेंडर्स ईमेल एड्रेस? भैया? लिया तो
सेंडर्स का ईमेल एड्रेस क्या है? फ्रॉम
यहां पे आपको दिख रहा है यह सपोर्ट@
tb.com
तो कॉपी ईमेल एड्रेस कर देते हैं। यहां पे
डाल देते हैं सप@b.com
जो भी है।
डन। ये इसका सेंडर ईमेल आईडी है। अब देखो
इंस्पेक्ट द ईमेल मैसेज सोर्स। चलिए ईमेल
मैसेज सोर्स को इंस्पेक्ट करते हैं। तो
व्यू पे चलते हैं। मैसेज सोर्स पे जाते
हैं और यहां पे हम इंस्पेक्ट करते हैं।
इंस्पेक्ट में क्या करना है कि व्हाट इज द
डिफेंड्ड एक्स ओरिजिन ओरिजिनेटिंग IPपी
एड्रेस? डिफेंड्ड एक्स ओरिजिनेटिंग IPपी
एड्रेस क्या है? तो भैया एक्स ओरिजिनिंग
IPपी एड्रेस तो यह है हमारा यह वाला 103
ये बट ये इसको चाहिए डिफेंड्ड IP एड्रेस।
तो हम डिफाइन कर सकते हैं। यह हम साइबर
शेफ से ही कर सकते हैं। साइबर सेफ के
प्लेटफार्म पे जब आप आएंगे यहां पे तो
यहां पर आप डिफेंग सर्च कीजिए।
देखिए डिफें IPपी एड्रेस का ऑप्शन आपको
मिल जाएगा। इसको हम पॉपुलेट कर लेते हैं।
डिफें डिफें IPपी एड्रेस पहले वाले को हम
हटा देते हैं यहां पे डिफें IPपी एड्रेस
कर देते हैं। ये आ चुका डिफाइंग आईपी
एड्रेस। अब हम इसमें इनपुट डालेंगे। हमारा
जो मेन IPपी एड्रेस है और ये आपको इसको
डिफेंग करके दे देगा। कुछ इस तरीके से
इसमें छेड़छाड़ करके नॉन क्लिककेबल बना के
दे देगा। सिंपल। तो ये हमने डिफें कर
दिया। अब हमने यहां पे डिफाइन IPपी एड्रेस
को पेस्ट करना है। चेक करना है। सही है?
राइट। कंटिन्यू एनालाइजिंग द ईमेल मैसेज
सोर्स एनालाइज करना चालू रखेंगे। व्हिच
मेल सर्वर जनरेटेड ऑथेंटिकेशन रिजल्ट्स
हेडर। अब इसमें एक ऑथेंटिकेट ऑथेंटिकेशन
रिजल्ट्स हेडर है। उसको कौन से मेल सर्वर
ने जनरेट करा है? तो हम देखते हैं
ऑथेंटिकेशन रिजल्ट कहां है? तो कंट्रोल एफ
करके हम सर्च कर लेते हैं। ऑथेंटिकेशन यह
रहा। ऑथेंटिकेशन रिजल्ट्स। यह हेडर है।
इसको कौन से मेल सर्वर ने जनरेट करा है?
तो यह वाली मेल सर्वर ने करा है। यह Yahoo
का है। एटस 102 free.mail डॉट जो भी है
gql.com जो भी डोमेन है ये इसने जनरेट करा
है। तो हमने इसको यहां पे पुट डाउन कर
दिया। चेक कर लिया। डन [संगीत] हो गया।
हो गया। ये हमने कर लिया। कंक्लूजन में आई
डोंट थिंक ये कुछ होगा। कंक्लूजन में भी
है कुछ क्या? क्या है? व्हिच अटैक सी हां।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
अब देखो यह सारी चीजें हो गई। अब बिफोर
मूविंग ऑन हम यहां पर कर इट्स आल्सोेंट टू
अंडरस्टैंड बिजनेस ईमेल कॉम्प्रोमाइज।
बिनेस ईमेल कॉम्प्रोमाइज क्या होता है?
बीसी क्या होते हैं? ये अ टाइप ऑफ़ अटैक
वेयर एन एडवर्सरी
गेंस एक्सेस टू अ लेजिटमेट इंटरनल ईमेल
अकाउंट एंड यूज़ इट टू ट्रिक अदर्स इनू
परफॉर्मिंग अनअथराइज़ ऑफ़ रेंट एक्शन। मतलब
बीसी का मतलब होता है बिज़नेस ईमेल
कॉम्प्रोमाइज़। अब कोई कंपनी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
में कोई ईमेल है, बिजनेस ईमेल है, उसको
किसी टाइफर ने कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया और
उसका यूज करके अब दूसरे एंप्लाइज को
टारगेट कर रहा है। सिंपल तो इसका एक नाम
रख दिया सॉरी सॉरी इसका एक नाम रख दिया
गया है बिजनेस ईमेल कॉम्प्रोमाइज। यह वही
है और क्या है?
डन।
हो गया। ये हमारा कंप्लीट हो गया। ये
सिंपल सा था। वी कंप्लीटेड इट। राइट? अब
हम यहां पे इसको तो बंद करते हैं। आते
हैं। एंड हम यहां पे नेक्स्ट आगे की तरफ
बढ़ते हैं। अब हम यहां पे फिशिंग ईमेल्स इन
एक्शन पे आते हैं। इसको हम देखते हैं। अब
देखो ये जो है इसमें थोड़ा सा आपको थोड़ी सी
एडवांस चीजें देखने को मिलेंगी। मजा बट
बहुत ज्यादा आएगा। एंड अभी आप देखते जाइए।
आपको आपको बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग लगेगा।
बेसिकली आपको ईमेल फिशिंग के बारे में
आपको थोड़ा जानकारी देना है। वह मैं आपको
इन सब के थ्रू प्रॉपर देता रहूंगा। अभी आप
बस ध्यान देते रहिए। बस दैट्स इट। सबसे
पहले आते हैं।
यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं है। हटा दो। यहां पे
है सबसे पहला कैंसिल योर ऑर्डर। ठीक है?
चलिए देखते हैं। अब इसमें क्या है?
इन दिस टास्क वी विल एग्जामिन अ सैंपल
ईमेल डिज़ टू मिमिक एन ऑफिशियल ट्रांजैक्शन
रिसीप्ट फ्रॉम PayPal। एक ऑफिशियल
ट्रांजैक्शन रिसीप्ट है PayPal की तरफ से।
उसको हम एनालाइज़ करेंगे। बाय एनालाइजिंग द
स्पेसिफिक एग्जांपल वी विल फोकस ऑन हाउ
अटैकर्स लेवरेज
स्पव्ड ईमेल एड्रेस टू इंपर्सनेट ट्रस्टेड
सर्विसेस। ट्रस्टेड सर्विसेस को कैसे वो
इंपर्सनेट करते हैं। ठीक है? स्पूव्ड ईमेल
एड्रेस का यूज़ करके। एंड स्ट्रेटजीस
यूज़ ऑफ़ स्ट्रेटेजिक यूज़ ऑफ़ यूआरएल
शॉर्टनिंग सर्विस टू ऑफ फस्टकेट द फाइनल
डेस्टिनेशन ऑफ़ मलेशियस लिंक्स। और यूआरएल
शॉर्टनर्स का यूज़ करते हैं ताकि
डेस्टिनेशन ईमेल को हाइड करके रखा जा सके।
तो फिशिंग टेक्निक्स कौन-कौन सा यूज़ हुआ
है इस पर्टिकुलर टास्क में? स्पूवफ्ड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ईमेल एड्रेस
यूज़ हुई है। ईमेल एड्रेस को स्पूफ किया
गया है। यूआरएल शॉर्टनिंग यूज़ किया गया
है। और ब्रांडेड HTML का मतलब इंपोर्सनेट
करने के लिए कि भैया थोड़ा सा ऑथेंटिसिटी
दिखाने के लिए ये टेक्निक्स यूज़ की है।
फर्स्ट ऑब्जरवेशन हम देखते हैं। लेट्स
फर्स्ट लुक एट द सैंपल ईमेल हेडर एंड टेक
अ फ्यू नोट्स ऑफ़ आवर इमीडिएट ऑब्जरवेशन।
सबसे पहले यह जो आप है यह आप देख रहे हैं।
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे कि जो मेल आया है
यह कहां से आया है। यह देखिए वेयर दिस मेल
हैज़ कम फ्रॉम इट्स फ्रॉम sv@ paypal.com
यह मेल आया है sv@ paypal.com ऑथेंटिक लग
रही है। बट इसके अंदर जो लिंक है वो लिंक
देखिए नो रिप्लाई exए कुछ भी एक गार्बेज
लिंक है।
एक मलेशियस लिंक है
और टू टू कहां पे यह आपका
टू है राइट तो ये एक किसी भी तरह की मेल
से आई है sv@ paypal.com और व्हिच डू नॉट
मैच द एक्चुअल एड्रेस। यह एक्चुअल एड्रेस
आपका है जो कि यह है गिबिश@न
बोर जो भी है व्हाटएवर यह आपका एक्चुअल
एड्रेस है। तो इससे मैच नहीं करता। हमारा
एक्चुअल एड्रेस यह वाला है जिस पे आना
चाहिए। लेकिन इसका एड्रेस क्या है? कुछ और
ही है। नो रिप्लाई एक्स कुछ करके ऐसे
करके। तो यह फर्जी एक एड्रेस पे फर्जी
एड्रेस है। चलिए ईमेल बॉडी एनालिसिस करते
हैं। टेकिंग अ लुक एट द ईमेल बॉडी बिलो।
यह ईमेल की बॉडी है। कुछ इस तरीके से ईमेल
आई रहती है। हेलो कस्टमर यू सेंट अ पेमेंट
ऑफ $120 यूएसडी मतलब $120 टू अमेजिंग
स्टफ। यह अमेजिंग स्टफ किसी को भेजा जा
रहा है। $120 भेजा गया है। उसकी पूरी
रिसीप्ट है, डिटेल्स है मर्चेंट की। यह
कौन सा आइटम भेजा गया वो आइटम का डिटेल
यहां पे दिया हुआ है। 30 $30 का $30 का
आइटम है। यह अमेजिंग स्टफ गिफ्ट कार्ड चार
क्वांटिटी भेजी गई $120 की। 10 अब यहां पे
आ रहा है कैंसिल द ऑर्डर। कैंसिल बटन है।
इस ट्रांजैक्शन से कोई इशू है तो आप
कैंसिल कर दीजिए। ठीक है? अब यहां पे क्या
है? द ओनली इंटरेक्टिव एलिमेंट इन दिस
ईमेल इज कैंसिल द ऑर्डर बटन। इस पूरे ईमेल
में कैंसिल द ऑर्डर बटन जो है यह
इंटरेक्टिव है। क्यों? क्योंकि आपने तो
पेमेंट मान लो नहीं भेजा है। अब इसमें
बोला गया कि अरे आपको तो आपके PayPal से
$120 भेजा जा रहा है। तो अब यहां पे है
कैंसिल द ऑर्डर। मतलब आपको लगेगा अरे यार
$120 भेजा जा रहा है। तो इसको कैंसिल कर
देता हूं इस ऑर्डर को फटाफट। यह एक
इंटरेक्टिव वह है। अब बटन इन्वेस्टिगेशन
की बारी आती है। तो कैंसिल द ऑर्डर बटन पर
यहां पे एक लिंक दी हुई है। लिंक क्या है?
एचआरएफ जो आपको मैंने बताया था ना एचआरएफ
टैग होती है। तो एचआरएफ टैग के अंदर में
लिंक्स जनरेटेड एंबेडेड होते हैं। तो ये
देखिए एक लिंक दी गई है। आईएस डॉटg यह
अजीब सा लिंक है। आपको लगेगा अरे ये क्या
है? बट ये एक शॉर्ट एंड लिंक है। दिस इज़ अ
शॉर्ट एंड लिंक। शॉर्ट किया गया है। इसको
जब एक्सपेंड करेंगे तो यह लिंक आप देखो
कहां पे जाएगा। यह जब एक्सपेंड कर रहे हैं
इस लिंक को तो यह हमें ऑफिशियल Google के
लॉगिन पेज पर ले जा रहा है। एंड आप इसको
ऐसी टूल्स vय गोज़ जैसे टूल्स को यूज़ कर
सकते हैं लिंक चेकर का जहां पे आप लिंक्स
को चेक कर सकते हैं कि एक्चुअल में वो
रीडायरेक्ट कहां कर रही है। तो wgs.com
जैसे टूल्स हैं जिन पे आप कोई सा भी शॉर्ट
एंड यूआरएल को डालिए और
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] वो बताएगा कि
एक्सैक्टली ये लिंक कहां पे जो है वो
रीडायरेक्ट कर रही है। ठीक है? अब
हु इज लिस्टेड एज द मर्चेंट इन द ईमेल
बॉडी। अब इसमें मर्चेंट कौन है भैया? तो
देख लो यहां पे मर्चेंट इनेशन यहां पे
अमेजिंग स्टफ नाम से मर्चेंट है। सिंपल
कुछ भी नहीं है यह। अमेजिंग स्टफ
ये आपका मर्चेंट है। तो हमने यहां पे
मर्चेंट को डाल दिया। सॉल्व हो गया। अब
यहां पे है ट्रैक योर पैकेज। इस पे आते
हैं। ट्रैक पैकेज में देखिए क्या है?
फिशिंग टेक्निक्स। किसी भी अ ईमेल को
ट्रैक करना है। तो यहां पे हम यूज़ करेंगे
स्प्ड ईमेल एड्रेस। ठीक है? फिशिंग
टेक्निक्स जो यूज़ किए जाते हैं अटैकर्स के
द्वारा उसमें क्या यूज़ होता है? स्पव्ड
ईमेल एड्रेस। ठीक है? तो अगर मान लो कि
नेक्स्ट ईमेल विल विल इन्वेस्टिगेट
मिमिक्स अ फॉर्मल शिपिंग नोटिफिकेशन टू
ट्रिक रिसिपिएंट्स इंटू अ सेंस ऑफ़
अर्जेंसी। अब शिपिंग का एक नोटिफिकेशन
आएगा कि भैया आपका शिप हो गया है कुछ। ठीक
है? तो अटैकर ने क्या-क्या किया है? ईमेल
एड्रेस को स्पूफ किया है। वे ट्रस्टेड
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर टू गेन इमीडिएट
क्रेडिबिलिटी। दूसरा पिक्सेल ट्रैकिंग है।
इंबेडिंग इनविज़िबल इमेजज़ टू नोटिफाई द
सेंडर व्हेन द ईमेल इज़ ओपन। इसमें पिक्सेल
ट्रैकिंग भी है कि मतलब जैसे ही आप ईमेल
ओपन करेंगे अटैकर के पास नोटिफिकेशन चला
जाएगा कि भैया इसको तो एक्सेस किया जा रहा
है। ईमेल को खोला गया है। लिंक मैनपुलेशन
एंड फिर से वही कि मास्किंग अ मलिशियस
डेस्टिनेशन विथ अ फ्रॉडैंड ट्रैकिंग नंबर
और मलिशियस डेस्टिनेशन को एक ट्रैकिंग
नंबर से मास्क कर दिया गया है। ये यूज़ में
की गई है। एज एन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एसोसिएल
वन फर्स्ट ऑब्जरवेशन आपका क्या है?
सब्जेक्ट लाइन। अब आप देखेंगे
सब्जेक्ट लाइन जो है द सब्जेक्ट लाइन यूज
अ फेक ट्रैकिंग नंबर टू क्रिएट अ सेंस ऑफ
अ इरजेंसी। तो एक फेक ट्रैकिंग नंबर यहां
पे आपको देता है ताकि आपको लगे अरे यार यह
तो ट्रैकिंग नंबर आ गया। अब तो मेरी आइटम
सिर्फ शिप हो गई। अब अब क्या होगा? बड़ा
दिक्कत है यार। प्र्पिंग द रेिपिएंट टू
क्लिक टू सेव द पैकेज। ताकि आप इसको ओपन
करके पैकेज को देखिए। फ्रॉम एड्रेस। अब
देखो फ्रॉम एड्रेस क्या है यह? दिस इज़ एन
इमीडिएट रेड फ्लैग एज द डिस्प्ले नेम
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर डज़ नॉट मैच द
एक्चुअल सेंटर एड्रेस। ये अब
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर एक्चुअल सेंटर
एड्रेस क्या है भैया? कांटेक्ट एट द बज़िंग
Pro डॉट क्लब। तो ये क्या है?
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर यूआरएल कुछ और है।
यहां पे सेंटर सेंडिंग कुछ और हो रही है।
अजीब सा है। मतलब मलिशियस और सस्िशियस है।
हाइपरलिंक द लिंक इन द ईमेल बॉडी मैचेस द
सब्जेक्ट लाइन। ऑलदो वी डू नॉट नो वेयर इट
रीडायरेक्ट्स टू जस्टिएट। अब यहां पे जो
बेसिकली ईमेल बॉडी में लिंक है वो
सब्जेक्ट लाइन से मैच कर रही है। सब्जेक्ट
में आपका क्या है? ट्रैक योर पैकेज। यहां
पे लिखा हुआ है सेम टू सेम है। बट अब ये
रीडायरेक्ट कहां कर रही है? सबसे बड़ी बात
ये है। सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज ये है कि
रीडायरेक्शन देखना। तो अब हाइपरलिंक
ट्रैकिंग हम देखेंगे। तो जब हम इस
पर्टिकुलर को व्यू सोर्स करेंगे व्यू
सोर्स जैसे हम कर रहे थे तो हमें पता
चलेगा हाइपरलिंक डेस्टिनेशन के बारे में
जो कि यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके से आपको
दिखेगी एचआरएफ टैग के अंदर मैंने बोला था
एचआरएफ में लिंक्स होते हैं तो आपको इसमें
लिंक का डिटेल मिलेगा कि भैया ये
एग्जैक्टली ये कहां पे रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा
है तो ये रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है ये जो इस
पे ट्रैकर पैकेज है ये रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा
है इस पे डेट्सy
डे rेटxyz
483 जो भी है फलाने का ना यह इस पे ट्रैक
कर रहा है। ठीक है? और ट्रैकिंग पिक्सल
कहां लगी है? यह रहा डेरेट.xyz
क्रिएटिव्स ट्रैकिंग pnजी यह जो इमेज है
यह एक ट्रैकिंग पिक्सल है जो ट्रैक कर रही
है आपके जो भी आप इंटरेक्शन कर रहे हैं और
वो रीडायरेक्ट कर रही है इस यूआरएल के ऊपर
जो कि एक मलेशियस यूआरएल हो सकता है। इस
तरीके से आप हाइपरिक को एग्जामिन करते
हैं। मैसेज का सोर्स खोलेंगे। ईमेल का
सोर्स खोलेंगे और उसमें जो एचआरएफ होगी
जैसे मैं ओरिजिनल जो मैसेज यहां पे मैंने
खोला था तो यहां पे एचआरएफ टैग हम सर्च
करेंगे तो एचआरएफ टैग में आपको लिंक्स
मिलेंगे। तो आपको लिंक मिल गया। अब यहां
क्वेश्चन है व्हाट रूट डोमेन डस द
हाइपरलिंक
इन द रूट इग अबव एग्जांपल्स एग्जांपल
पॉइंट्स टू? तो कौन से रूट डोमेन को पॉइंट
कर रहा है ऊपर में? व्हाट रूट डोमेन डस द
हाइपरलिंक इन द अबव एग्जांपल पॉइंट्स टू?
ऊपर एग्जांपल में हाइपरलिंक में कौन सा
रूट डोमेन को पॉइंट कर रहा है? बताइए
मुझे। इसका आंसर दीजिए। रूट डोमेन क्या
है?
एवरीवन प्लीज रिसोंड गाइस जल्दी मुझे सबके
अ रिप्लाई चाहिए। प्लीज बताइए मुझे रूट
डोमेन क्या है?
ठीक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] है।
हां
देखो रूट डोमेन जो होता है ना ये जो आपका
एचटीटीपी एचटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल है उसके बाद
जो डोमेन आपका है स्टार्टिंग का वही रूट
डोमेन होता है
ठीक है
हां वही रूट डोमेन होता है। जैसे अगर मैं
मान लो डिफ्रॉनिक्स ओपन करता हूं यहां पे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] और मैं किसी
पेज पे जाता हूं। ठीक है? मान लो वेरीफाई
सर्टिफिकेट में जाता हूं। कुछ इस तरीके से
यह पेज ओपन हो गया। राइट? अब इसमें यह
पूरा रूट डोमेन नहीं है। रूट डोमेन होगा
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स ड.com यही बस रूट डोमेन हो
गया। बाकी आगे पीछे से कोई मतलब नहीं है।
सेम यहां पे द रूट डोमेन इज़ डेरेट डॉटxyz
ये रूट डोमेन है। बट यहां पे जो आंसर करना
है हमें क्या करना है? बी श्योर टू डिफेंग
द यूआरएल। हमें आंसर डिफेंग करके करना है।
अगर हम यहां पे डेरेट.com लिखेंगे ना
डेरेट.com
तो ये गलत आंसर होगा। ठीक है? क्योंकि यह
बोल रहा है डिफें कीजिए। तो ठीक है भैया
हम डिफें कर देंगे।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] साइबर शेफ पे
चलेंगे
और यहां पे डिफेंग यूआरएल वाला इसको हटाते
हैं। डिफें आ जाते हैं और यहां पे हमने एक
यूआरएल डाल दिया डेरेट
डॉट। तो ये इसका डिफेंड यूआरएल आ गया।
इसको कॉपी करते हैं और यहां पे हम डाल
देते हैं सिंपल। अब करते हैं इसको। एंड
दिस इज़ दिस शुड वर्क.com
क्या हुआ भाई?
स्पेलिंग सही है ना? ओके। एक xyz है। सॉरी
डेरेxyz है।
x yz है। तो हमने डेरे डॉट xyz यहां से
लिख लिया एंड हमने यहां पे xyz डाल दिया।
चेक कर लिया। ठीक है? दैट्स इट। तो हो गया
ये सिंपल। तो ये डिफेंग वाला काम हो गया।
ठीक है? आपको गाइज़ मजा आ रहा है आप लोगों
को? आप लोगों को कुछ चीजें सीखने को मिली
है। नई-नई चीजें डिफें हो गया और अभी तो
और बहुत सारी चीजें मिलेंगी जो टेक्निक्स
हो रही हैं। ईमेल को सोर्स को ईमेल के
सोर्स को देखना कि IP एड्रेस कैसे निकालते
हैं उसके थ्रू किस तरीके से लिंक्स को चेक
आउट करते हैं। ये सारी चीजें आपको अभी
बहुत सारी चीजें हैं जो अभी आपको पता
चलेगा अभी।
तो एक बार [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
रिप्लाई कर दीजिए सभी लोग। इफ यू आर
अंडरस्टैंडिंग
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अरे
ग्रेट मैvिक स्क्वायर ये जो स्क्वायर
ब्रैकेट है वो इसलिए दिया गया है यही तो
डिफेंड का मतलब है स्क्वायर ब्रैकेट लगा
दिया मतलब ये क्लिककेबल यूआरएल अब नहीं रह
जाएगा ना दिस विल नॉट बी अ क्ल क्लिकबल
यूआरएल अब तो ये क्लिकबल अब नहीं रह
जाएगा। ठीक है? तो अब तो गलती से किसी से
क्लिक नहीं होगा तो आप बच जाएंगे फिशिंग
के अटेमप्ट से। यही इसका मेन मोटिव है।
सिंपल
समझ में आ गया?
योर बग बंटी कोर्स इज़ वेरी गुड। थैंक यू
वेरी मच। आई एम ग्लैड दैट यू आर एंजॉयंग द
बक बंटी।
समझ में आ गया?
नॉन क्लिकबल बनाने के लिए है वो। फिर से
ये ट्राई एककमी का नाटक शुरू हो गया। अभी
तक सही था। फिर से रीलोड मार दिया मैंने।
लेट्स होप कि
हां कर सकते हो। डिफाइन कर सकते हो। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। लेकिन एक स्टैंडर्ड
होती है डिफाइन करने की। एक स्टैंडर्ड
फॉलो होता है। उसके लिए वो साइबर शेफ का
यूज़ किया जा रहा है। एक स्टैंडर्ड होता
है। एक होता है ना कि हां एक पर्टिकुलर
स्टैंडर्ड जो हर जगह पे सेम तरीके से काम
करे। इसलिए हम साइबर शेफ जो है उसको फॉलो
कर रहे हैं। चलिए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यह क्या हो गया? ट्राईकमी का फिर से गजब
हाल है भाई। यह तो चलो कोई बात नहीं। अब
यहां पर आ जाते हैं डाउनलोड डॉक्यूमेंट
हियर। ये तो हो गया हमारा डाउनलोड
डॉक्यूमेंट हियर। क्या है? व्हाट इज़ दिस
डाउनलोड डॉक्यूमेंट हियर? इन दिस टास्क वी
विल एनालाइज़ फिशिंग कैंपेन दैट यूटिलाइज़ज़
अ मल्टीस्टेज रीडायरेक्शन चेन टू
हार्वेस्ट यूजर क्रेडेंशियल। अब एक फिशिंग
कैंपेन हम एनालाइज़ करने जा रहे हैं। जहां
पे मल्टी स्टेज रीडायरेक्शन चेन है। और
इसका यूज़ क्यों किया जाता है? ताकि टारगेट
से हम क्रेडेंशियल्स को चुरा सके। अटैकर
जो है टारगेट से क्रेडेंशियल चुरा सके। यह
इसका मेन मोटिव है। दिस
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सैंपल
डेमोंस्ट्रेट हाउ अटैकर्स लिवरेज द
रेपुटेशंस ऑफ प्रोफेशनल डॉक्यूमेंट
शेयरिंग सर्विज। अब प्रोफेशनल डॉक्यूमेंट
शेयरिंग जो सर्विज होते हैं जैसे वन
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ड्राइव, AOB,
Microsoft तो इनका यूज करके
और यह एक डिसेप्टिव पाथ बनाते हैं जिससे
कि जो विक्टिम है वह एक फ्रॉडलेंट या
मशियस लॉगिन पोर्टल पे चला जाता है। उसको
लगता है कि हम सही जगह पे हैं। वहां से वो
लॉगिन करना लॉग इन एक्सेस करना चाहता है।
चीजों को डाउनलोड करना चाहता है। बस यह
चीज़ें हम इस पर्टिकुलर अटैक अह में देखने
वाले हैं। तो, यहां पे फ़िशिंग टेक्निक्स
क्या-क्या यूज़ हुई है यहां पे जो अटैकर है
क्या-क्या फिशिंग टेक्निक यूज़ करेगा
इसमें? आर्टिफिशियल अर्जेंसी अर्जेंसी
क्रिएट करेगा भैया जल्दी-जल्दी करने के
लिए। ब्रांड इंपर्सनेशन
ट्रस्टेड ब्रांड्स जैसे Microsoft, AOB इन
सबका इंपॉर्सनेशन करेगा। मिमिक्री
डुप्लीकेसी लिंक रीडायरेक्शन लिंक को
रीडायरेक्ट करने का काम यह करेंगे और
क्रेडेंशियल हार्वेस्टिंग यानी कि हमारे
लॉगिनस फेक लॉगिन पोर्टल्स का यूज़ करके और
लॉगिन करने की कोशिश की जाएगी। तो पहला
ऑब्जरवेशन आपका क्या रहेगा? सेंड डेट। अब
देखिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
द ईमेल वाज़ सेंट ऑन थर्सडे जुलाई 15th
2021। जुलाई 15, 2021 को ईमेल सेंड किया
गया है। राइट?
जुलाई को एक्सपायरेशन डेट अ सेंस ऑफ
अर्जेंसी इज इंट्रोड्यूस इन दिस ईमेल। एक
सेंस ऑफ अर्जेंसी क्रिएट की गई है। किस
तरह का? नोटिस दैट द लिंक टू डाउनलोड द
फैक्ट डॉक्यूमेंट एक्सपायर्स ऑन द सेम डे।
यहां पे आपको भेजा गया भी है 15 जुलाई को
मेल। और आपको जो एक्सपायरी का लिंक है,
एक्सपायरी का जो टाइम दिया गया है, वह भी
सेम डे का ही है। तो अब इतनी भी जल्दी
क्या है भैया? आप अपने से यही पूछोगे जब
ऐसे ही सब आप एग्जामिन करोगे इतनी जल्दी
क्या है एक्सपायर होने की? यार आराम से
टाइम लेके एक्सपायर हो जाओ। तो ये
अर्जेंसी क्रिएट की जा रही है। अर्जेंटली
तुम उस पे एक्शन लो भाई एक्सपायर
एक्सपायर। डाउनलोड डॉक्यूमेंट हियर बटन।
अब यहां पे एक बटन दी गई है डाउनलोड
डॉक्यूमेंट हियर। अब भाई इस डाउनलोड में
क्या है अंदर? कौन सी फाइल है? किस तरह की
फाइल है? कुछ पता ही नहीं है मुझे। तो मैं
डाउनलोड करूंगा मलिशियस रोड फाइल
डॉक्यूमेंट डाउनलोड हो गई तो पीडीएफ
डॉक्यूमेंट डाउनलोड हो गई तो मलिशियस
वाली। क्या करोगे?
देयर इज़ एन एक्शन टू परफॉर्म इन दिस केस द
बटन टू डाउनलोड द फैक्ट्स। ये एक्शन है।
यह कहानी है। अब यहां है डाउनलोड
डॉक्यूमेंट हियर। देखो अब आफ्टर क्लिकिंग
द डाउनलोड डॉक्यूमेंट हियर बटन यूजर इज़ली
डायरेक्टेड टू अ लैंडिंग पेज दैट
मेक्सिक्स अ लेजिटमेट वन ड्राइव शेयर। अब
जैसे ही इस पे क्लिक करेगा यूजर तो यह
एक्चुअली एक रियल
डाउनलोड वन ड्राइव के वेबसाइट पे ले जाएगा
जो एक्चुअल वन ड्राइव की वेबसाइट की तरह
दिखेगी रियल वाली। बट उसका यूआरएल शैडी
होगा। उसका यूआरएल जो है ना वो खतरनाक
लगेगा। उसका यूआरएल ओरिजिनल वन ड्राइव
Microsoft की यूआरएल की लिंक नहीं होगी।
फेक लिंक होगी और यहां पर आपको रहेगा गेट
डॉक्यूमेंट। फिर साइन नहीं कीजिए अपने
Google अकाउंट से या आउटलुक से ऑप्शन आपको
दिया जाएगा। ठीक है? द यूआरएल इज़ हाइली
सस्िशियस। अब यहां पे क्या है कि जब आप यह
करेंगे तो यूआरएल काफी सस्िशियस होगा। एंड
प्रोवाइडेड डायरेक्शंस आर नॉनसेंसिकल।
नॉनसेंस है। दीज़ इनकंसिस्टेंसीज़ लीड टू
फाइनल ट्रैप। अ क्रेडेंशियल हार्वेस्टिंग
पोर्टल दैट आस्क विक्टिम टू साइन इन विद
देयर ईमेल प्रोवाइडर। बस आप अपने ईमेल
Google, Facebook लॉग इन कीजिए और आपका
Google अकाउंट पासवर्ड आ जाएगा। अब आता है
लॉगिन इन। अब आपसे लॉगिन होकर आएगा जिसमें
आपसे यूजरनेम पासवर्ड मांगा जाएगा और
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड जब वो डाल देंगे तो वो
उसका जो उसकी जो डिटेल है वो अटैकर के पास
चली जाएगी। सर ट्राईक पेड है क्या? हां जी
ट्राईक पेड और फ्री दोनों ही सर्विज ऑफर
करता है। तो ट्राईक इज पेड आल्सो एंड फ्री
आल्सो फ्री वाले भी अवेलेबल है। तो आप
फ्री वर्जन यूज़ कर सकते हो उसके लिए। पेड
वालों के लिए आपको पे करना पड़ेगा। ठीक है?
कुछ रूम्स फ्री है, कुछ रूम्स पेड हैं।
ऐसे तो यहां पे आप ईमेल पासवर्ड डालेंगे
एंड आपका वहां पे जो है वो ईमेल पासवर्ड
अटैकर के पास चला जाएगा। ठीक है? दैट्स
सिंपल। द अटैकर डेप्लॉयड अ फेक लॉग इन
पोर्टल्स टू कैप्चर एन एक्स फ़िल्ट्रेट
यूजर क्रेडेंशियल्स। फेक लॉग इन पोर्टल
सेटअप किया अटैकर ने यूजरनेम पासवर्ड को
गेन करने के लिए। तो इस अटैक को क्या
बोलते हैं? व्हाट इज दिस टाइप ऑफ़ अटैक
कॉल्ड? बताइए मुझे। जब एक फेक पोर्टल को
यूज करके ईमेल्स पासवर्ड को गैदर करने की
कोशिश की जाए, चुराने की कोशिश की जाए, तो
ऐसे फेक पोर्टल्स को क्या बोलते हैं? फेक
पोर्टल्स वाले अटैक को हम किस तरह के अटैक
को इस तरह क्या अटैक कौन सा अटैक होता है?
हां, इसको हम बोलते हैं क्रेडेंशियल
हार्वेस्टिंग।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इसको हम बोलते हैं क्रेडेंशियल
हार्वेस्टिंग।
वी आर राइट। करेक्ट। अब आते हैं योर
अकाउंट इज़ ऑन होल्ड। अब आपका अकाउंट होल्ड
पे है। अब एक ऐसा फिशिंग अटेम्प्ट होगा
जिसमें कि आपका अकाउंट होल्ड पे चला
जाएगा। ठीक है? सो, मुझे 1 मिनट का समय
दीजिए। मैं थोड़ा सा पानी पी लेता हूं।
मैं
मैं माइक्रोफोन ऑफ कर रहा हूं ताकि आपको
किसी तरह की आवाजें जो है वह ना आए।
आई होप यू अंडरस्टैंड जस्ट गिव मी वन
मिनट।
आपको आवाज फिर भी जा रही है?
आपको आवाज अभी भी जा रही है ना? मैं
माइक्रोफोन ऑफ कर रहा हूं तब भी आवाज जा
रही है ना?
आवाज अभी भी जा रही है
क्योंकि
यहां से माइक्रोफोन ऑफ करने का कोई ऑप्शन
नहीं है।
चलिए मैं यहां से ऑफ करके देखता हूं।
ओके मैं म्यूटेड में ही बोल रहा था सो
[हंसी]
आई वाज हैविंग डेट बाइट्स
ओके मैं म्यूटेड में ही बोल रहा अ
दिस दिस इज़ डेट बाइट्स
राइट तो इट्स अ गुड थिंग इसमें छह
इंग्रेडिएंट्स होते हैं जिनसे ये मिलके
बना होता है। कोई कैशज़ होते हैं जो काजू
होता है आपका पिस्तचू होता है। एलमंड्स
होता है पता ही होगा आपको। डेट्स होते
हैं। खजूर वगैरह जो होता है। हनी जो शहद
होती है और घी होता है। इन सब से मिलकर
बना होता है। कोई एडेड शुगर नहीं होती है।
कोई भी अलग से आपको जो है मीठा जो है वो
इसमें एडेड नहीं होता है। ठीक है?
तो दिस इज व्हाट आई एम।
एक और है बस उसको मैं खा लूं क्योंकि बहुत
जोर से भूख लगी थी लिटरली।
ओके गाइस सो आई एम बैक नाउ एंड आई होप कि
आई एम ऑडिबल क्लियरली नाउ मुझे एक बार बता
दीजिए
अभी ऑडियो आ रही है
स्नाइपर गेमिंग बस थोड़ा सा वेट कर लीजिए
और ऑडियो इज क्लियर गाइस ऑडियो अभी आ रही
है सबको
और जो भी जा रहे हो लाइक ठोकते जाना भाई
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ऑडिबल
ओके कंपनी फार्मली है फार्मली फार्मली
कंपनी है
एफ ए आर एम एल इ वाई चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] चलिए इनका
प्रमोशन हो गया वैसे फ्री का
इस बात पे अब डब्बे भेज दे तो अच्छी बात
है ओके यहां पे आ रही है अकाउंट इज ऑन
होल्ड अब इस वाले
अटैक को देखते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब यहां पे एक एक अकाउंट होल्ड का अटैक है
जो अटैकर की तरफ से होगा। उसमें क्या है
कि Netflix बिलिंग का यूज़ हम यहां पे करा
जा रहा है। क्या होगा कि ईमेल एक ट्रस्टेड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जो है
प्लेटफार्म ट्रस्टेड डोमेन जो है वहां से
आ रही है। व्हाइल
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] प्रीवियस केसेस
मे बी हैव रिलायड ऑन मेलेशियस लिंक्स। दिस
वैरिएंट इंट्रोड्यूस अ शैडी अटैचमेंट।
इसमें क्या है? Netflix के तरफ से आ रही
है। एंड यहां पर एक शडी अटैचमेंट है। एक
मलेशियस अटैचमेंट हो सकती है। बाय
मैस्कुडरिंग एस एन ऑफिशियल बिलिंग
नोटिफिकेशन एन अटैकर अटेम्प्ट्स टू बाईपास
स्टैंडर्ड ईमेल फिल्टर्स एंड लेवरेज द
विक्टिम सेंस ऑफ़ अर्जेंसी। अब यहां पे एक
फेक बिलिंग नोटिफिकेशन भेजी जाएगी जो कि
एक ऑफिशियल की तरह दिखाया जाएगा और अटैकर
क्या करेगा कि वो ईमेल फिल्टर्स को बाईपास
करने की कोशिश करेगा और आपके इमर सेंस ऑफ
अर्जेंसी को यूज़ करने की कोशिश करेगा। तो
यहां पे फिशिंग में क्या-क्या चीजें हो
रही हैं? पहले हम उसको पेट नहीं भरा यार।
पेट थोड़ी ना भरते हैं। देखो तुम लाइफ में
खाने के लिए जीवन तुम्हारा खाने के लिए
नहीं है। ठीक है? ऐसा नहीं है कि जीवन तुम
जी रहे हो खाने के लिए। खाना बस ऐसे खाओ
कि जियो। जीने के लिए खाओ। है ना? खाने के
लिए मत जियो। तो पेट थोड़ी ना भरना है यार।
ऐसे पेट भर लो तो फिर तो नींद आ जाएगी।
फिर [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] पढ़ाएगा
कौन तुम्हें? चलो। यहां पे अटैकर के
द्वारा फिशिंग टेक्निक कौन सी यूज़ हुई है?
फर्स्ट विल सेट। यह किसने भेजा भाई? गिफ्ट
क्या है?
सेंड अ गिफ्ट। किसी ने गिफ्ट भेजा है
क्या?
सेंड समोसा। अच्छा ऐसा ऐसे भी गिफ्ट्स आते
हैं क्या?
क्या बात है।
धन्यवाद भाई समोसे गिफ्ट के लिए। अच्छा यह
बताइए आपने जो समोसा गिफ्ट भेजा है, यह
क्या पैसे से आपके आपको पे करना पड़ा है
क्या इसके लिए? तब आए हैं क्या?
अ तन्मय मतलब आप ऐसे ही भेज पाए या आपको
पे करना पड़ा इसके लिए यह गिफ्ट जो समोसा
वाला भेजा है [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अच्छा अच्छा फ्री पॉइंट्स है मतलब पे करना
पड़ता है जनरली ऐसा है लग रहा है मुझे तभी
तो वो आप भेज पा रहे हो चलिए नई चीजें
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके अब इसमें कौन-कौन से फिशिंग टेक्निक्स
यूज़ हुई हैं? स्पूफ्ड ईमेल एड्रेस। तो
ईमेल एड्रेस को स्पूफ किया गया है। सेंड
यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं कि सेंडर्स
डिस्प्ले नेम इज़ सेट टू Netflix बिलिंग।
आप देख सकते हैं Netflix बिलिंग के नाम से
है। ईमेल एड्रेस से स्पूफ करने की कोशिश
की गई। सेंस ऑफ़ अर्जेंसी। अर्जेंसी क्या
है भैया? योर अकाउंट इज ऑन होल्ड। अरे बाप
रे घबरा गया। अकाउंट होल्ड हो गया। ब्रांड
इंपर्सनेशन। Netflix का लोगो यूज़ किया
गया। ब्रांड इंपर्सनेशन। ठीक है? यह सबसे
बड़ी चीज है।
पुअर ग्रामर एंड टाइपोज़। पुअर ग्रामर और
टाइपोज़ का यूज किया गया है। पुअर ग्रामर
और टाइपोज़ का। कैसे? नोटिस नोटिसेबल
स्पेलिंग ऑफ Netflix। अब आप देखेंगे यहां
पे Netflix का यहां पे बिलिंग Netflix
बिलिंग जो लिखी हुई है उसमें नेट N नेटल्स
बिलिंग का आ रहा है। यहां पे अटैचमेंट
यूज़िंग अ फाइल अटैचमेंट रादर दैन अ
डायरेक्ट लिंक टू हाइड द मलेशियस यूआरएल।
अब यहां पे एक अटैचमेंट जो है ना यहां पे
यूजिंग अ फाइल अटैचमेंट रादर दैन अ
डायरेक्ट लिंक। तो फाइल अटैचमेंट का यूज़
किया जा रहा है। जहां पे एक अटैचमेंट
पेमेंट अपडेट कुछ ऐसा अपडेट दिया जा रहा
है ताकि जो है
उसके थ्रू लिंक्स को विजिट कराया जाए। ठीक
है? तो ये सारी चीजें आपको यहां पे देखने
को मिल जाएगा। अब यहां पे अगेन हेलो
कस्टमर आपके यूजरनेम और इसके
अकॉर्डिंग नहीं है। कस्टमर डायरेक्ट ईमेल
बॉडी एंड अटैचमेंट एनालिसिस के ऊपर आते
हैं। टेकिंग अ लुक एट द ईमेल बॉडी यू कैन
सी यूजर इज़ इनफॉर्म दैट देयर इज़ एन इशू
विथ द बिलिंग इनफार्मेशन। बिलिंग इनेशन से
आपको इंफॉर्मेशन आई है। इन ऑर्डर टू अपडेट
देयर अकाउंट दे मस्ट ओपन द अटैच पीडीएफ
फाइल। अब मतलब अकाउंट को अपडेट अगर करना
है तो आपको यह पीडीएफ फाइल ओपन करनी ही
पड़ेगी। जी इफ यू डू नॉट आस्क टू रिसेट
योर पासवर्ड यू मे वांट टू रिव्यू योर
रीसेंट अकाउंट ठीक है वी आर एबल टू अपडेट
योर पेमेंट मेथड और यहां पे है पीडीएफ
अटैचमेंट ठीक है ओके कोई बात नहीं है
पीडीएफ अटैचमेंट है यहां पे
द अटैचमेंट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कंटेंस एन एंबेडेड लिंक टाइटल्ड अपडेट
पेमेंट मेथड अपडेट पेमेंट मेथड जो है जो
आपका यह बटन है यह एक लिंक कंटेन करता है
व्हिच रीडायरेक्ट्स द यूआरएल नॉट
एसोसिएटेड विथ अ लेजिटिमेटate Netflix
डोमेन अब यह एक ऐसे यूआरएल पे लेके जाएगा
जो एक्चुअली Netflix से एसोसिएटेड नहीं
है। रियल Netflix का डोमेन नहीं है। वी
विल इन्वेस्टिगेट दिस ईमेल इन डिटेल इन द
नेक्स्ट रूम। हम उसको नेक्स्ट रूम में
इन्वेस्टिगेट करेंगे। देयर इज़ अ कपल अदर
पॉइंट्स। कपल ऑफ़ अदर पॉइंट। द यूज़ ऑफ़ एन ए
टिपिकल फोन नंबर फॉर्मेट इन इज़ अ रेड
फ्लैग। ए टिपिकल फोन नंबर फॉर्मेट। अजीब
सा एक फॉर्मेट फॉर्मेट यहां पे शो यूज़
किया जा रहा है। यह भी थोड़ा सस्िशियस है।
यूजिंग अ लेजिटमेट Netflix हेल्प सेंटर
डोमेन टू बिल्ड अ फॉल्स सेंस ऑफ़ ट्रस्ट।
और एक रियल एस एस हेल्प.com डोमेन को यहां
डाल दिया गया है ताकि फॉल्स ट्रस्ट क्रिएट
हो सके यूजर के बीच। ठीक है? ये इस तरीके
से आपका Netflix होल्ड वाला चीज काम
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] करता है। तो
व्हाट इज द एक्चुअल सेंडर ईमेल एड्रेस
हिडन बिहाइंड द Netflix बिलिंग डिस्प्ले
नंबर। सेंडर ईमेल एड्रेस क्या है? Netflix
बिलिंग के तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
सेंडर ईमेल एड्रेस क्या है? Z99 उसके बाद
यहां पे क्या है? mza comb.in
mza comb ऑनलाइन यही ईमेल एड्रेस है बस
यही तो है और क्या तो z99@
mz कॉमb अ डॉट
क्या है म्यूजा कॉमबी ऑनलाइन तो डॉट
ऑनलाइन सिंपल दैट्स इट [संगीत]
मजा आ रहा है बहुत अच्छी बात है अब आ रहा
है योर रीसेंट परचेस अब इसमें भी यहां पे
सेम चीज है मैं इस पे ज्यादा ये मतलब मतलब
थोड़ा आपको वैसे बता देता हूं क्योंकि
इसमें कुछ है नहीं वैसा रीसेंट परचेस भी
ये भी एक तरह का अटैक है फिशिंग का है।
इसमें अटैकर ने क्या यूज़ किया है? स्पूफ
ईमेल एड्रेस यूज़ किया है। रिसिपिएंट इज
बीसीसी बीसी सी बीसीसी एट। बीसीसी का मतलब
होता है सिंपली द विक्टिम इज़ नॉट
डायरेक्टली सेंट द मेल। किसी और को भी मेल
किया जा रहा है। लेकिन बीसीसी जो है सीसी
बीसीसी उसमें आपको आपका ईमेल आईडी डाला
गया है। अर्जेंसी रिलज ऑन एक्शन
रिक्वायर्ड एंड अ फेक परचेस नोटिफिकेशन
मतलब एक फेक परचेस का नोटिफिकेशन आपको डाल
दिया गया है। पुअर ग्रामर एंड टाइपोज़
बेकार ग्रामर टाइपोज़ यूज़ में लिया जा रहा
है। स्पेलिंग एरर्स है। हेडर में उसको आप
देख सकते हैं। पुअर अटैचमेंट्स और
अटैचमेंट्स है द ईमेल कंटेन्स अ डॉट फाइल
Microsoft वर्ड टेंपल्लेट व्हिच इज़ एन
अनयूज़ुअल फॉर्मेट फॉर अ रिसीप्ट मतलब
रिसीप्ट में डॉट डॉट फाइल कौन सी होती है
भाई डॉटdओटी
सर रिसीप्ट जनरली आपका पीडीएफ में होगा
ज्यादा ज्यादा आपका एक्सेल में हो सकता है
ऐसी चीज़ फॉर्मेट होती है डॉट क्या है तो
फर्स्ट ऑब्जरवेशन ईमेल सब्जेक्ट है आपका
आप सब्जेक्ट देखिए द रिसिपेंट इज़ टोल्ड दे
मस्ट एक्ट क्विकली टू रिॉल्व मतलब तुरंत
आप इसको रॉल्व कीजिए नहीं तो दिक्कत हो
जाएगी। क्रिएटिंग अ फॉल्स सेंस ऑफ
अर्जेंसी आपका अर्जेंसी दिखा रहा है। ठीक
है? तो यह आपका एक फॉल्स सेंस दे रहा है।
फ्रॉम एड्रेस Apple सपोर्ट है लेकिन
एड्रेस में क्या है भैया? डोमेन कुछ और ही
है। Apple सपोर्ट से है लेकिन डोमेन यहां
पे कुछ और है। सब सुप्रीम.com कुछ डोमेन
है। अजीब सा। ब्लाइंड कार्बन कॉपी। द
रिपिएंट वाज़ नॉट डायरेक्टली ईमेल्ड
इंस्टीड ब्लाइंड कार्बन कॉपीड। मतलब
ब्लाइंड कार्बन कॉपीड का मतलब यहां पे आप
इस पे जब क्लिक करेंगे बेसिकली तो ईमेल के
अंदर में ब्लाइंड कार्बन कॉपी जो होती है
यह सिंपल सा है कि यूजिंग द बीसीसी फील्ड
टू सेंड एन ईमेल मैसेज टू अ लार्ज ग्रुप
ऑफ़ पीपल हैज़ अ नंबर ऑफ़ बेनिफिट्स
इंक्लूडिंग ये बेनिफिट्स हैं। लेकिन यहां
पे ब्लाइंड कार्बन कॉपी जो है यह जो फील्ड
है इसको यूज़ करने का मतलब यहां पे सिंपल
सा है कि आपके अलावा यह और भी लोगों को
ईमेल भेजी जा रही है या आपको मेन मेल आईडी
मेन आपके रिसिपिएंट में आप नहीं है लिस्ट
में तो आपको बीसीसी में डाल दिया गया है।
अब अटैचमेंट के एनालिसिस को देखेंगे तो
यहां पे एक डॉट फाइल है भैया। ठीक है? अब
यहां पर फर्दर एनालिसिस वगैरह करेंगे तो
आपको यहां पे डिटेल्स इसकी अटैचमेंट्स की
आप एनालिसिस कर सकते हैं जो कि हम अभी
नहीं करेंगे वो नेक्स्ट वाली अ लैब के लिए
है। तो फिलहाल बीसीसी क्या स्टैंड करता
है? तो ब्लाइंड कार्बन कॉपी ब्लाइंड
कार्बन कॉपी इस पे स्टैंड करता है। व्हाट
इज द फाइल एक्सटेंशन ऑफ़ अटैचमेंट? तो जैसा
कि मैंने बताया डॉट डॉटdओटी डॉट ठीक है?
बस हो गया। ये इतना ही था बस कि अब ऐसे
रीसेंट परचेस के थ्रू आप ऐसे कर दिया। अब
शेड्यूल्ड शिपमेंट इसमें भी वही चीजें सेम
है। शेड्यूल्ड शिपमेंट्स में शिपमेंट में
क्या करा जा रहा है? फिशिंग अटेम्प्ट दैट
मस्कुर रेड्स एज अ ग्लोबल शिपिंग
नोटिफिकेशन यूजिंग स्प्ड एड्रेस एंड अ
ब्रांडेड hटीएमl टू अपीयर एस लेटमेट। अब
एक ग्लोबल शिपिंग नोटिफिकेशन आ रही है कि
भैया डीएचएल एक्सप्रेस कूरियर ने आपकी कोई
चीज शिप की है। शिपिंग का नोटिस है और
आपको यहां पे शिपिंग का नंबर दे दिया जा
रहा है। शिपिंग का नंबर भी दे दिया जा रहा
है। थैंक यू फॉर शेड्यूलिंग अ कूरियर
शिपमेंट। अब आपको अर्जेंसी दिखाई जा रही
है कि भैया ये शिपिंग कब कर दिया यार?
इतनी अर्निंग ये अटैच और शिपिंग का नंबर
जानबूझ के दिया गया है ताकि आपको लगे कि
अरे यार ये शिप हो गई है। और इसमें यूज़
क्या किया गया डीएचएल एक्सप्रेस जो
ऑथेंटिक एक डीएचएल सर्विस है उसको यूज़
किया गया है। लेकिन उसमें ग्लैमर यह कंपनी
क्या है? ग्लैम कार कंपनी एक फेक कोई सी
भी डोमेन यूज़ की गई है। तो रियल है नहीं
ये और यहां पे आपको दे दिया गया है ये
चीज़। अब इसमें क्या है? बेसिकली क्या है?
ब्रांड का इंपोशनेशन किया जा रहा है।
डीएचएल का ईमेल बॉडी अटैचमेंट देखें तो एक
फाइल दी गई है जिसमें जो कि एक एक्सls
एक्स फाइल है। एक फाइल दी गई है जो कि एक
एक्सls फाइल है। एक्सेल की फाइल है। तो
अगर आप ओपनिंग करेंगे इस डॉक्यूमेंट को तो
अंदर में आपको डिटेल्स मिलेंगे। और इसके
अंदर जब आप इसको ओपन करेंगे तो आपको कुछ
ही अजीब सा मतलब कि इनकंसिस्टेंसीज़ आपको
इस फाइल के अंदर अजीब सा कुछ डाटा मिलेगा
जिसके अंदर कुछ खास आपकी जानकारी होगी
नहीं। फर्स्ट द सेंडर यूजसेस अ जर्मन
डोमेन द इनवॉइस इज़ एड्रेस टू अ सिटी इन
इंडिया। जर्मन डोमेन है बट इंडियन सिटी के
लिए इनवॉइस्ड है। ये द डॉक्यूमेंट कंटेन
इटसेल्फ कंटेन मैंडेरियन। डॉक्यूमेंट के
अंदर मेंडेेरियन अलग ही लैंग्वेज है।
चाइनीज़ लैंग्वेज है। दिस कन्फ्लिक्टिंग
ज्योग्राफिकल मार्केट्स मार्कर्स आर
क्लासिक्स रेड फ्लैग। ये एक रेड फ्लैग्स
है। ठीक है? एंड यह आपको देखने चाहिए। अब
द एग्जीक्यूटेबल। अब यहां पे
एग्जीक्यूटेबल क्या है? यह देखना। जो
हमारा व्हेन द लिंक विद इन द एक्सेल
डॉक्यूमेंट इज क्लिक। अब इस एक्सेल
डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर में एक लिंक है। यह
हाइपर लिंक यहां पर डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर
लिंक है। टू ट्रांसलेट लैंग्वेज काइंडली
क्लिक इनेबलिंग एडिटिंग अबव। तो यहां पे
एक लिंक है। तो ट्रांसलेट करने के लिए ऊपर
में इस पे क्लिक करना पड़ेगा। तो व्हेन द
लिंक इज़ क्लिक इट अटेम्प्ट्स टू डाउनलोड
एंड एग्जीक्यूट अ मलेशियस पेलोड नेम्ड
यहां पे रेगा sms.exc यह पेलोड को डाउनलोड
करने का अटेम्प्ट करेगा। रहेगा sms डॉट
exc एज़ सीन इन द स्क्रीनशॉट दिस
एग्जीक्यूशन रिजल्ट्स इन अ सिस्टम एरर
जैसे ही आप इसको डाउनलोड करेंगे ये एक
सिस्टम एरर आएगा क्या? कुछ इस तरीके से
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
जैसे आपको यहां पे सिस्टम एरर यहां पे
देखने को मिल रहा है। ठीक है? अब जब ऐसा
सिस्टम एरर आया तो आप समझ जाइए कि जो आपका
अटैकर है वो आपके डायरेक्ट सिस्टम के अंदर
कोड एग्जीक्यूट करना चाह रहा है एंड कई हद
तक वो सक्सेसफुल भी हो चुका है। कोड हैज़
बीन एग्जीक्यूटेड।
बस अब यहां पे इफ सक्सेस सक्सेसफुली
एग्जीक्यूटेड द अटैकर कुड एस्टैब्लिश
पर्सिस्टेंस बैकडोर क्रिएट कर लेगा।
शेड्यूल टास्क को जो है वह कंट्रोल करेगा
और पर्सिस्टेंस इस्टैब्लिश कर देगा।
कंप्यूटर रिबूट करेंट, शट डाउन करेंगे,
वापस से रिस्टार्ट करेंगे, वापस से आपका
कंट्रोल आपके कंप्यूटर का अटैकर के पास
चला जाएगा। एक्सिल्ट्रेट डाटा डेटा को
सेंसिटिव फाइल्स को, इनेशन को चुरा लेगा।
डिप्लॉय रैंसमवेयर, रैंसमवेयर डिप्लॉय कर
सकता है। जहां पे आपसे आपके फाइल्स को लॉक
कर दिया जाएगा। डिलीट करने के नाम पे,
रिकवर करने के नाम पे आपसे पैसे मांगे
जाएंगे। ये सारी चीजें यह यहां से होगी।
व्हाट इज द नेम ऑफ़ एग्जीक्यूटेबल दैट द
एक्सl अटैचमेंट अटेम्प्ट्स टू रन? तो,
यहां पर नेम रहेगा SMS.ex है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कॉपी किया, पेस्ट किया, चेक किया।
गॉट इट? दैट्स इट सिंपल। सर, यू आर 100%
बेटर देन माय कॉलेज फैकल्टी एनआईटी कॉलेज।
अरे ऐसा मत बोलो यार।
ऐसा [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मत बोलिए।
टेक एनरी।
डिप्लोमा कंप्लीट इन 2023 एंड अभी फाइनल
बीटेक में आया और एसओसी डोमेन चूज़ किया सर
आपकी वजह से सर। लव यू सर जी फ्रॉम नागपुर
महाराष्ट्र। लव यू टू ब्रदर। एंड थैंक यू
वेरी मच। आई एम ग्लैड दैट यू आर लविंग इट।
थैंक यू फॉर योर वर्ड्स। तो ये हो गया
दैट्स इट। खत्म। यहां पे कंक्लूजन में कुछ
है नहीं। यहां पे कंक्लूजन खत्म कर देते
हैं। राइट? दैट्स इट। खत्म।
ये थी आपकी ये पर्टिकुलर रूम। अब यहां पे
एक फिशिंग एनालिसिस टूल्स करके रूम है।
नाउ दिस रूम इज़ अ प्रीमियम रूम। दिस रूम
जो है ये जो रूम है ये एक प्रीमियम रूम
है। ठीक है? अब ये प्रीमियम रूम जो है
इसमें कुछ चीजें आपको देखने को सीखने को
मिलेंगी। इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें देखने को
मिलेंगी। यहां पे आप मजा आएगा आपको। सो
बेसिकली
इस प्रीमियम रूम में फिशिंग एनालिसिस
टूल्स के बारे में हम जानने वाले हैं। वी
विल बी लर्निंग अबाउट फिशिंग एनालिसिस
टूल्स एंड ऑल। ये सारी चीजें। तो मुझे अब
आपसे क्वेश्चन यह पूछना है कि क्या हम यह
प्रीमियम रूम्स के लिए नेक्स्ट क्लास के
लिए रहने दे सकते हैं या आज ही कराओ। जैसा
आप बोलेंगे वैसा मैं कर दूंगा। सो, लेट मी
नो। क्योंकि वैसे भी इस क्लास के लिए,
फिशिंग के लिए एक क्लास में तो पॉसिबल था
ही नहीं। इसके दो-तीन क्लासेस हो सकते हैं
क्योंकि फिशिंग का कंटेंट बहुत बड़ा है।
और दूसरी चीज मुझे आपको और भी बहुत सारी
चीजें बतानी है इसके अंदर में। ट्राईक के
अलावा चीजें बतानी है। तो वो चीजें भी मैं
आपको बताऊंगा। अलग-अलग टूल्स हैं, अलग-अलग
वेबसाइट्स हैं। वो मैं आपको बताऊंगा जो कि
बहुत सारी इसके थ्रू भी कवर होंगी। बहुत
सारी अलग से भी होंगी। तो व्हाट यू
सजेस्ट? शुड वी स्टॉप टुडे सेशन हियर एंड
प्रीमियम रूम्स को हम आगे कवर भी करेंगे
और इसके अंदर की चीजों को भी देखेंगे या
कैसे करें बताइए
बताइए सभी लोग प्लीज बताइए नेक्स्ट क्लास
भाई नेक्स्ट क्लास आज ही करवा दो नेक्स्ट
क्लास नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट डे।
हां, मैं भी वही सोच रहा हूं। अ चलो
नेक्स्ट क्लास के लिए काफी लोग बोल रहे
हैं क्योंकि एक्चुअली हमारा टाइम भी हो
गया है। 2 घंटे ऑलरेडी हो चुके हैं और
बहुत ज्यादा एक्सटेंड करेंगे। फिर 3 घंटे
क्योंकि अगर ये मैंने शुरू किया तो लगभग 3
घंटे हो जाएंगे। मतलब लगभग 1 घंटा सवा
घंटा के आसपास लगे। थोड़ा थोड़ा सा बड़ा
है। थोड़ा सा टाइम लगेगा आपको समझाने में।
तो 1 घंटा लगभग आपको देना पड़ेगा उसके
लिए। तो फिर यह 3 घंटे की वीडियो हो
जाएगी। लंबी हो जाएगी फिर। सो ज्यादातर जो
आ रहे हैं कमेंट्स वो आ रहे हैं नेक्स्ट
क्लास के लिए। ज्यादा प्रोबेबिलिटी उधर
ज्यादा वो है। मतलब वोटिंग उधर की है। तो
ठीक है। नेक्स्ट क्लास के लिए हम इसको
रखते हैं। लेकिन नेक्स्ट क्लास आपकी जल्दी
ही आएगी। ऐसा नहीं है कि बहुत तो उसमें
लेट होगा। ठीक है? ज्यादा गैप नहीं होने
वाला है नेक्स्ट क्लास के लिए। बहुत जल्द
मैं लेकर आऊंगा और इन रूम्स को हम डिस्कस
करेंगे। यह प्रीमियम रूम्स हैं। आपको इसकी
सब्सक्रिप्शन अगर स्पेशली इसके लिए ले रहे
हैं तो लेने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी आपको।
मैं आपको यह रूम करवा भी दूंगा। एक-एक चीज
आपको बता भी दूंगा। आप नोट्स बस बना लेना
वीडियो के थ्रू। आपका कंप्लीट हो जाएगा।
यू डोंट नीड टू परचेस दिस पर्टिकुलर फॉर
दिस पर्टिकुलर रूम। सिंपल।
ठीक है?
हां। तब तक आप सभी से रिक्वेस्ट है कि
यहां पे मैंने आपको फिलहाल आज जो भी आपको
चीजें बताई हैं ट्राईक मी पे जाना है।
एसओसी वाली जो एसओसी एल1 वाली जो रूम्स
हैं उसमें आपको देखने को मिलेगा फिशिंग
एनालिसिस का सेक्शन। इसमें आप आएंगे और ये
जो दो रूम्स हैं फिशिंग एनालिसिस
फंडामेंटल्स और ईमेल्स इन एक्शन। ये दोनों
में टाइम भी ज्यादा इसलिए लगा है क्योंकि
इसमें आपको समझाना था। आगे प्रैक्टिससेस
करनी है तो आपको थोड़ा-थोड़ा जैसे मतलब
मैं कोशिश करूंगा कि खत्म करने का नेक्स्ट
क्लास में इसको एंड इसको हम आगे करेंगे।
तो ये प्रीमियम रूम्स हैं। फिर उसके बाद
यहां पे सीटीएफ है। अ फ्लैग्स आपको ढूंढने
हैं। वो भी काफी इंटरेस्टिंग होगा। तो हम
ये करेंगे। राइट? मजा आएगा। मतलब हम रूम्स
भी करेंगे और सीटीएफ चैलेंज भी है। एक
चैलेंज भी है कि कैसे आप एनालाइज करते हो
मलेशिया ईमेल को और उसमें से क्या-क्या
फाइंड करते हो। तो बहुत मजा आएगा। बट ये
सारे प्रीमियम है। तो मैं आपको करके वो
चीजें बताऊंगा। तो हमारा फिशिंग तब जाके
कंप्लीट होगा। फिशिंग बहुत बड़ा वो है।
उसके पहले मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं। आप
सब से एक रिक्वेस्ट है कि आप सभी जो भी
यहां पर देख रहे हैं इन वीडियोस को इन
क्लासेस को इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट टू गो एंड
एक्सप्लोर द नेटवर्किंग कांसेप्ट्स।
क्योंकि नेटवर्किंग का बहुत बड़ा रोल है
एसओसी में। मैं आपको जरूर बताऊंगा बट
स्टिल मैं आपसे रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं कि आप
प्लीज खुद से भी एक बार एक्सप्लोर
कीजिएगा। नेटवर्किंग का बेसिक कांसेप्ट ले
लीजिए और उसके लिए आप हमारे ही YouTube
चैनल पर जाइए। सिंपल सब चीजें अवेलेबल है
यार। मजा आया आपको। हमारे YouTube पे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी पे जाइए। हमारे YouTube
पे आप प्लेलिस्ट सेक्शन में जाइए। एंड इसी
में जब आप नीचे की तरफ स्क्रॉल करेंगे तो
आपको नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी फ्री ट्रेनिंग
मिलेगी। व्यू फुल कोर्स फुल से प्लेलिस्ट
कीजिए। और इसमें जितने भी वीडियोस आपको
दिख रहे हैं लगभग 13 वीडियोस आप उन 13 के
13 वीडियोस को देख जाइए। आपका नेटवर्किंग
वाला कांसेप्ट बहुत ज्यादा क्लियर हो
जाएगा। उसके अलावा मैं भी कराऊंगा। उसके
लिए आपको बेफिक्र रहना है। बट आप प्लीज यह
काम जरूर कर लीजिएगा। इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट
फ्रॉम एवरीबॉडी। उसके अलावा इसमें आपको
वेब सिक्योरिटी मॉनिटरिंग का भी नॉलेज
लेना है। अब वेब सिक्योरिटी मॉनिटरिंग में
आप देखेंगे वेब अटैक्स यहां मेंशंड है।
DOS डीडीएस मेंशंड है। तो वेब अटैक्स
जितने भी वेब अटैक्स जैसे मैं वेब अटैक्स
पे ठीक है। मैं यहां पे वेब सिक्योरिटी
इंसेंशियल और वेब अटैक्स दोनों ओपन करता
हूं। फिलहाल के लिए आपको दिखाने के लिए।
एक ओवरव्यू दे रहा हूं फिलहाल। अब वेब
अटैक्स में देखेंगे तो यह वेब के बारे में
सारी चीजें उसका इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर और ये
सारी चीजें सब बता रहा है। तो ये तो चलो
हम कवर करेंगे इसको बिल्कुल करेंगे।
डिफेंस सिस्टम्स ये सारी चीजें नॉर्मल सी
चीजें हैं। उसके बाद है वेब अटैक्स। इसमें
आप देखेंगे ओएस टॉप 10
आपका क्लियर होना चाहिए। ओएस टॉप 10 का
कवरेज है यहां पे। वायर शार्क का कवरेज है
यहां पे। ठीक है? ये सारी चीजें कवरेज है।
तो आप देखेंगे यहां पे अलग-अलग सर्वर साइड
अटैक्स हैं। अब सर्वर साइड अटैक्स में
अलग-अलग अटैक्स आएंगे। यहां पे लॉग बेस्ड
डिटेक्शंस के हैं सारी चीजें। तो इसके लिए
हमारा जो YouTube चैनल है आप उस पे
जाइएगा। वेब से रिलेटेड अटैक्स अगर आपको
समझने हैं तो डिफ़ॉन एकडमी ओपन कीजिएगा।
यहां पर प्लेलिस्ट आपको देखने को मिलेगी।
प्लेलिस्ट में जाइएगा तो आपको बग बंटी का
प्लेलिस्ट मिलेगा। व्यूफ प्लेलिस्ट बग
बंटी में मैंने ओएस टॉप 10 पूरा कवर किया
है। पूरा उससे ज्यादा ही कवर किया है।
आपसे रिक्वेस्ट है कि आप इस सीरीज के
पैरेलल वेब अटैक्स को समझने के लिए बग
बंटी की सीरीज को देख सकते हैं। मैं यह
नहीं बोल रहा हूं कि आप बग बंटी कीजिए। यू
डोंट यू डोंट गो थ्रू दिस सीरीज और दिस
प्लेलिस्ट फॉर बिकमिंग अ बग बंटी हटर।
बट आप उसके अंदर की कंटेंट को सीखने के
लिए लर्न लर्न करने के लिए वो स्किल्स गेन
करने के लिए इसको देखिए।
ठीक है बस तो यह जरूर आप इसके वीडियोस को
देखिएगा पैरेलली आप देखिएगा यह क्योंकि
लिंक्ड है उससे थोड़ा सा तो आप देख
लीजिएगा तो आपके लिए बेटर होगा हालांकि
मैं सब कुछ डिस्कस करूंगा आपको उसके लिए
बेफिक्र रहना है बट स्टिल मैं आपको एक बता
दे रहा हूं कि जब भी आप फ्री रहे जब भी
आपके पास टाइम हो तो आप इन चीजों को देख
लीजिएगा बस फिर हम आगे कंटिन्यू करते हैं
नेक्स्ट हमारे क्लास में मैं यहां पे मशीन
ऑन है क्या
आई थिंक मशीन बंद हो गई थी ना ओके वैसे भी
नहीं चल रही है तो इसको बंद ही कर देते
हैं।
ठीक है? बस नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम आगे की
तरफ बढ़ेंगे। फिशिंग का हम बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज जो है वो करेंगे नेक्स्ट
क्लास में। नेक्स्ट क्लास में क्योंकि हम
चैलेंज को करेंगे और मजा आएगा आपको। तो
प्लीज इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट कि नेक्स्ट क्लास
में जरूर आप प्रेजेंट रहिएगा। बहुत जल्दी
हम नेक्स्ट क्लास लेकर आएंगे। फिलहाल के
लिए हम टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट और कुछ आपके
चैट्स मैसेजेस वगैरह आपके क्वेरीज देख
लेते हैं। तो ये हमारी टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट
है जिसमें कि यूजुअली जितने लोग होते हैं
जनरली आई थिंक आई एम सीइंग दोज़
पीपल यह टॉप फेंस की लिस्ट है। थैंक यू
वेरी मच। आप लोग इतनी कंटिन्यूटी दिखाते
हैं। यह मुझे काफी अच्छा लगता है। आज
थोड़े कम लोग थे क्योंकि उनको लगा कि
ट्राईक का है तो बट एक्चुअल चीजें वो मिस
कर जा रहे हैं कि जो मैं एक्सप्लेन कर रहा
हूं चीजों को वो बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। आप
प्लीज इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट। ठीक है? तो ये
हमारे टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट है। भाई साहब लोग
जो हमेशा ज्यादातर एक्टिव रहते हैं। एंड
यहां पे आ जाते हैं चार्ट लिस्ट में। एंड
देन हम ब्रदर आई डू नॉट हैव अकाउंट ऑन
Lindin द द फोन थ्रू व्हिच द नंबर एंड
Gmail आई हैड माय Lindin वाज़ स्टोलन। द
रिकवरी Gmail वाज़ आल्सो। ओके कोई बात
नहीं।
Finance कॉम आप शायद वही है ना जो जिनके
हस्बैंड ने एक बार Lindin पे हमारे पोस्ट
पे कमेंट किया था और आपके बारे में शायद
बताया था कि यू आर वाचिंग एसओसी
फ्रॉम अस एंड यू आर लाइक आपने काफी अच्छा
उनको शायद बोला था कि काफी अच्छा इनका
कोर्स है। एंड आपके हस्बैंड ने शायद शेयर
भी करा था उसको काफी जगह पे और बताते भी
हैं, शेयर भी करते हैं। आप भी करते होंगे
शायद। आप वही है क्या? फाइनेंस
कॉम
मुझे ऐसा लग रहा है इसलिए मैंने पूछ लिया।
बाकी आई डोंट नो। अ सर प्लीज गिव द क्लास
अपडेट अ डे इन एडवांस। यू आर ऑलरेडी
यू आर रेडी ऑलरेडी। ओके। ठीक है।
ठीक है। नॉट इट।
ओके।
सर दिस इज माय फर्स्ट लाइव बिकॉज़ पीछे था
बट आज अटेंड करने मिला। एंड थैंक यू। हां
मैंने फाइंड कर लिया है आप ही हैं। तो अब
अगर आपने ये लिखा है कि ओह माय गॉड यू
फाउंड तो आप ही होंगे फिर। चलिए अच्छी बात
है। थैंक यू वेरी मच। ये हमारे व्यूअर हैं
जो
अह अह काफी लोगों को एसओसी की वीडियोस को
शेयर करते हैं। एंड इनके हस्बैंड ने
Lindin पे कमेंट करके और स्क्रीनशॉट भी
दिया था। अ कि हम शेयर करते हैं लोगों को
आपके एसओसी की प्लेलिस्ट एंड उनके हस्बैंड
भी शायद इसी मतलब टेक डोमेन में है शायद
कोई। सो इट वाज़ ग्रेट। काफी अच्छा लगा यह
देख के कि पीपल आर एक्चुअली शेयरिंग वि द
वीडियोस एंड वो लोगों को रिकमेंड करते हैं
कि आप जाइए एसओसी की प्लेलिस्ट को देखिए।
इन प्लेलिस्ट को देखिए क्योंकि उनको अच्छा
लगता है यह प्लेलिस्ट। अगर वो पसंद करते
हैं तभी शेयर करेंगे। तो थैंक यू वेरी मच
फ्रॉम बॉटम ऑफ माय हार्ट। काफी अच्छा लगता
है ऐसी चीजें जब मैं देखता हूं एंड आई होप
कि सभी लोग शेयर करते होंगे। कुछ लोग बता
भी देते हैं। कुछ लोगों के बारे में नहीं
पता वो भी शेयर करते होंगे। तो थैंक यू
वेरी मच। जाने से पहले लाइक ठोक के चले
जाइए। शेयर कर दीजिएगा वीडियो को। वीडियो
जब अभी अपलोड हो जाएगी तो उसको हाइप कर
दीजिएगा। जितना हाइप करेंगे उतनी लोगों तक
पहुंचेगी। एंड शेयर करते रहिए। बस दैट्स
इट। मैं आपके लिए कंटेंट लेता आता रहूंगा।
राइट? एंड जो जल्द एथिकल हैकिंग वीडियो भी
आ रही है। मजा आएगा आपको। सभी लोग
देखिएगा, शेयर कीजिएगा। थैंक यू वेरी मच
एंड हैव अ गुड नाइट टू एवरीबॉडी। लेट्स
मीट इन द नेक्स्ट सेशन नेक्स्ट क्लास।
बाय। गुड नाइट। शुभ रात्रि।